This is Jocko podcast number
63 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
I am an American fighting man.
I serve in the forces which guard
my country and our way of life.
I am prepared to give my
life in their defense.
I will never surrender
of my own free will.
If in command I will
never surrender my men.
While they still have the means to resist,
they find him captured.
I will continue to resist.
By all means available.
I will make every effort to escape.
I will accept neither parole nor
special favors from the enemy.
If I become a prisoner of war,
I will keep faith with
my fellow prisoners.
I will give no information or take part
in any actions which might be harmful to
my comrades.
If I am senior,
I will take command.
If not,
I will obey the lawful orders of those
appointed over me and we'll back them up
in every way.
When questioned,
should I become a prisoner of war,
I am bound to give only
name, rank, service number,
and date of birth.
I will evade answering further
questions to the utmost of my ability.
I will make no oral or written statements
disloyal to my country and its allies
or harmful to their cause.
I will never forget that I am an
American fighting man responsible for my
actions and dedicated to the
principles which made my country free.
I will trust in God and in
the United States of America.
Yeah.
And that
is the 1955 version of the code of
conduct for the armed forces of the United
States.
Okay.
And it was written in response
to the brutal treatment.
Yeah.
Right.
Of the 7,190 Americans captured by
the enemy during the Korean War,
prisoners who were subjected to torture,
indoctrination,
brainwashing,
and forced confessions.
And that version of the code that I just
read is almost exactly the same as the
one that I learned in the military.
When I joined in 1990
they did
make some changes to it.
They changed it to include men and women
and they changed two words to give some
flexibility to increase survivability
and psychological recovery from torture.
And so the little changes that were made
at it changed from the prisoner being
bound to give only name,
rank and service number and date of birth
to the prisoner being required to give
name, rank, service
number and date of birth,
small changes.
But the spirit of the
code didn't change at all.
And that code is what we as military
fighting men and women were and are
expected to uphold should we ever be
captured and held as prisoners by the
enemy.
Code of conduct is simple and
clear and straightforward,
but the code of conduct gets tested on
like any other document in the world
when our American servicemen
and women are somehow captured
and as prisoners of war face
absolutely ruthless levels of torture,
pain, suffering, disease, starvation,
humiliation,
and perhaps the most
devastating hopelessness.
And tonight it is my absolute honor
to have one of these men here,
one who during almost a full year of
horror upon horror at the hands of his
captors and Vietnam man,
who persevered and fought with every
ounce of his soul to survive against the
worst possible conditions imaginable.
Oh man,
that not only learned the code of conduct,
but lived it
a retired army colonel
William bill reader.
Sir, thank you so much for being
here tonight. Thank you, Jackie. Oh,
it's my honor indeed to be here and
participate in this podcast as well.
Thank you.
I want to just before
we jump into the book,
if you could just talk a little
bit about you growing up,
what you did,
what
you were like, where you were. Oh boy.
Okay. I didn't know this was coming.
Um, yeah, it was essentially a kid
off the streets of Los Angeles.
I was born in Glendale, grew up for
a time in the San Fernando Valley,
which is in the opening prologue
to the, to the book. Um, yeah,
I had a tough childhood,
I guess I would say. Um,
got into some trouble as
a, as a young guy, uh,
sports helped me at least survive
to graduate from high school, uh,
left college. Uh, and I,
and I went off to college at University
of Idaho to study forestry. Uh,
I left college and less than the
than esteemed academic terms.
After only one year, uh,
worked for a time as a, uh,
I worked all the time as a
kid with various small jobs,
newspaper routes and selling
magazines to door to tour. Um,
then did some construction work in, in my
early teens roofing work. Uh, but yeah,
after I left college, I worked
cattle ranches for awhile. Uh,
worked for the US Forest Service for
a time, a ultimately as a firefighter.
I got laid off in the end of fire season,
went back home to Los Angeles and found
a job with southern California Edison in
Santa Monica, climbing power
lines as a apprentice Lineman,
and did that until the
outbreak of the Vietnam War.
And then found my real niche in life
when I walked into the army recruiter in
Santa Monica, California. And
the sign on the dotted line,
what you was at 1965.
So you know,
the Tonkin Gulf incident
occurred, that's where the, uh,
the US destroyers were attacked in 1964.
We put Marines ashore in
Denang and March of 1965,
that's when I started
talking to recruiters.
First I was going in the Marine Corps,
uh,
but somehow ended up enlisting in the
army, uh, in a, in August of 1965.
And then what was the transition
to becoming a pilot? Yeah,
so I started out enlisted,
uh,
went to basic training and advanced
individual training ait. I was 80,
can't Ken, Ken Kennedy Ear, a member
of a cannon crew and an artillery unit,
and then applied for
officer candidate school.
And they took those with
the highest test scores.
You had to pass this
through of interviews. Uh,
but they were looking for officers
and especially artillery lieutenants.
And so I went to artillery officer
candidate school, six months of a,
of training with some degree of harassment
and then got commissioned in August
of 1966 as a second
lieutenant and artillery.
And then how long did you artillery
for before he became a pilot? Yeah,
that was about a year. I didn't
think I was going to be able to fly.
And that's really why I
didn't go in the Marine Corps.
I wanted to be a pilot
throwing two services.
You could fly without a college degree.
So this college dropout had hopes in
either the Marine Corps or the army. Uh,
when I went and saw the marine recruiter,
he gave me a battery of tests
and he said, and he said, yeah,
you qualify for a flight
and we can guarantee you a
flight training. I said, okay.
So what do I have to do?
Is, is you just go in,
as long as you pass a flight physical,
you're good to go.
So I could sense there was
something, uh, of put here.
So before I went in and I went to a FAA
flight surgeon in Santa Monica said,
give me the same flight the military
does and tell me if I could pass it.
So he gave me the physical and said,
no, you wouldn't pass it. He said,
you're right. Eyes about 20, 25
to 2030. You have an astigmatism.
They require a perfect 20, 20 vision.
You couldn't pass the flight physical.
So I wrote off the Marine Corps. I wasn't
going to do that. And I, I went into the,
uh, into the army instead thinking I
would never fly after I went to officer
candidate school,
I get commissioned,
I was working in an artillery
assignment at Fort Carson,
Colorado and went in for an annual
physical. And when I got the physical,
it came back 20, 20, both eyes. So I was,
I was in like Flynn took that down to
the flight surgeon and put my application
in and a,
and one off to flight school.
Awesome. Awesome. And so I'm going to,
I'm going to jump into
the book here. You, um,
you spent your first tour in Vietnam,
I think as your first tour in Vietnam.
You were flying the Mohawk, right.
Okay. So first tour in Vietnam.
And by the way,
you know,
we were talking before the podcast about
how much risk you guys took in Vietnam
as pilots. It's, it's actually crazy
and we'll get into more than that.
But one of the things that struck me as
I'm in the beginning of your book and
you're talking about how you got shot
down on your first deployment to Vietnam
as a pilot. So, so here, here's
you telling that story to your,
your crew when you're going on your
second deployment that you said. Yeah,
the first couple of operations we've
done here, they've been pretty exciting.
But you know, I had some good ones
on my last deployment too by the way.
It got shot down and uh,
so here I'm going to go to the book here.
This is what happened when you
got shot down for the first time.
It took a 37 millimeter milometer
antiaircraft hitting the right wing,
attacking a fuel depot,
hit hidden under the trees,
classified mission in Laos
over the Ho Chi Minh trail.
I pulled up from a rocket run,
wham.
The whole right side of the
aircraft seemed to explode.
We tumbled out of control. The right wing
shattered and was on fire, worked hard,
got back some ability to fly,
got the fire out,
but we were descending fast,
could not hold out the Tude.
Gave the command to eject.
The Observer went out,
I pulled my seat handle right after
I had a very short parachute ride,
only got partial shoot deployment
before hitting the ground with a thud.
We are crashing through the tree
tops by the time I punched out. So,
so for those people that don't know
what all that means is right there,
that means you know, when you pull
an ejection handle on, uh, on, uh,
when you're in a plane,
it ejects you out.
But you're supposed to do it with
some level of altitude, right?
Not when you're hitting the tree tops.
So you're hitting the tree tops in that,
in the canopy,
not opening all the way.
That means that the full usage
of the parachute isn't there.
It's just sort of getting opened
and then boom, it hits the ground.
My way, man, took a picture of my shoot
down site and you can see the, uh,
the parachute is just all strung out
and I'm laying there at the end of the
parachute. I mean, I never
got a single isolation.
I got a partial shoot
deployment and hit the ground.
I'm glad we can sit here and laugh at say,
am I offending by laughing at this?
I hope not. No, you're not. Because I
mean you made a comment about, you know,
taking the hits and I the attention
to come. And it was, it really was.
But there's something crazy about
young men. Uh, and uh, and uh,
at that point in my life I was a kid
living a dream and I got blown out of the
sky and my first tour. Yes, I survived it.
And somehow in my crazy twisted mind,
I couldn't wait to get back
over on his second tour,
Flying Cobra attack
helicopters. Hey, by the way,
so this is what happens once you get on
the ground. Here we go back to the book.
Then I was newly captured.
I ran through the jungle 45 minutes while
my wing man put down suppressive fire
that earned me the nickname.
Lightfoot got plucked out of the jungle
by an Air Force helicopter from the 20th
Special Operations Squadron
Out of Thailand called the
call side Pony Express.
Spent some time in the hospital there.
Eventually I returned to
the unit back to flight
duties. This is incredible. We
lost 15 airplanes at that point.
Out of 1830 crew members shot down.
Not many of them ever recovered.
I was one of the few lousy odds.
I was scared. Then I'll tell you,
if you don't get scared in combat,
you're a liar or nuts.
Only after tents mission is over.
Does the real fright come when
there's time to sit and think?
You watch it all play out in your mind
and wonder how the hell you live through
something like that.
Okay,
so again, we were talking before, before
we pressed record about the, you know,
about how protective America
is of its aircraft right now.
I can't even imagine.
You guys had 15 out of 18
airplanes that were shot down.
That's,
that's insane.
Yeah, and that was a
sophisticated, expensive aircraft
for the army at the time,
though. The Mohawk was pretty much
top of the line technology, arm,
army aircraft then.
Yeah,
very. Yeah. That's,
that's a totally different
mentality that than we have now.
Totally different mentality.
Yeah. And that was a special unit.
We had five Mohawk companies
in Vietnam at that time. Uh,
four of them were for each of the four
core tactical zones inside of south
Vietnam. They flew missions and
supportive of those areas. Uh,
we were the fifth company, the Bastard
Company. We flew out of way Phu Bai.
The only time we saw South Vietnam
was for take offs and landings,
all of our missions when it allows
her up off the coast of North Vietnam.
And then I had one highly classified one.
I had to deploy down to Todd snoot
at Saigon to go into Cambodia. Uh,
that I didn't know what
that was all about. It was
really hush hush at the time.
And that was in the advance of
the big Ang, Cambodia and curves.
And that took place in 70.
They developed the Mohawks for Vietnam
because it's interesting aircraft.
It's a side by side right in,
it's a prop plane to that twin turbo prop.
Others built purely for reconnaissance
and surveillance, Grumman,
Grumman aircraft.
Um,
but then you guys went ahead and put
missiles on them or rockets. We put,
we put rocks in. There were
Zuni missiles forever. Yeah,
we had rockets and pod mounted
machine guns. Uh, that, yeah,
that led to my cobra
experience because I really,
that was my favorite mission where
the gun missions in the Mohawk,
not all of them were armed, but I, I liked
the gun missions. Uh, when I came back,
my first tour, there was a spat
between the army and the air force.
And the result of the spot was we had to
take all the armament off the Mohawks.
So when I went back on second tour,
I wanted to go on a gunship,
not something without guns.
So that got me into cobras.
Yeah, that's weird. Those
bureaucratic spats happening,
decisions like that get made.
That's really disturbing.
So let's get into your second tour,
right?
And I'm going to jump into this piece
here. Back to the book. On April 14th,
we received a radio call that Firebase
Charlie was under attack by two regiments,
3000 soldiers of the 320th Nva Infantry
Division and 130 million meter artillery
shells were pounding the position.
So you guys get this call, this,
this friendly basis
being overrun basically.
And here you show up on the
scene. Now you're fine. A Cobra,
which for those of you that don't
know a Cobra gunship as you just said,
it's still in service today.
The Marine Corps stuff flies growers
like overs and very narrow skinny.
It's based on a Huey,
right?
Yeah, it was, you know,
the Helio was designed and went to Vietnam
and that most of our smaller with the
Huey, the Huey took on a gun
mission though that, that uh,
in Vietnam we saw the utility
had guns on our aircraft. Uh,
so the Cobra then was designed
specifically and only as
a gunship and they took
the Huey design, narrowed it down
to 36 inches pilot in the backseat,
copilot gunner in the front seat,
2.75 rockets on the wing stores,
a mini gun and 40 million or million or
grenade launcher in a movable knows to
it.
And it was one killing machine.
Okay.
And it's still apparently brings a giant
smile to your face when you talk about
that, which is lovely. And I
don't want to seem twisted. Yeah.
And I, I sat at the time I was a, I
was a kid living a dream and I was,
but I don't want to take away
from the horror of combat.
And it was scary as crap. Yeah.
On, on every single mission.
But there's still something about
a young guy, uh, going to war,
at least a certain type of young guy.
Uh,
and those that were in the two units
I served in, uh, that, uh, yeah, we,
we were dedicated what we did and I think
we did it well and I'm still smiling
about it.
Thank you.
So far, every guy had brought in to this
podcast has the exact same attitude.
So you're among friends here.
So I'm going now you guys are,
you guys are there, you show up with your,
when you're Cobra's back to the book,
we made several passes on enemy guns,
bullets stream past our cockpits as
the NVA gunners tried to bring us down.
Rolling in on a 51
physician is always dicey.
So this is a 51 caliber. It's a
dish, it's a, it's an anti aircraft,
aircraft machine gun. And they actually
had those when we were in Ramadi.
They had still had dish gets
and they use them against us.
Tracers come at you
and miss by a few feet.
You try to get rockets onto him before
he gets lucky and blast you out of the
sky.
We took small arms,
hits my knees vibrated
like a sewing machine,
but I focused on
controlling the helicopter,
lining up the gun sights and shooting.
I was scared, but had no time for it.
Dan radioed dusty cyanide panther one
three panther one three be advised,
running low on fuel out of Ammo.
We're breaking station for
re arm refuel. Roger, one,
three, four gun crews taken
out. Good work. Hurry back.
So you're your to ring to the
guy on the ground. Who's there?
So there's an American advisor on the
ground with a bunch of south Vietnamese
soldiers. They're being overrun. You
come in, you're taking heavy fire,
but you're giving backfire.
You tell them, hey,
we got to go and get some more
ammunition. He's saying, good job,
hurry back.
And when you do show up back,
the NVA attack is now more intense.
And here's the call that you get when
you show back up panther. That's you.
By the way, Panther Pink Panther's
as your, as you guys want to call,
as your call sign is panther.
Here's the call you get panther,
the battalion commander
is dead acting commander,
wounded enemy broken through on
the southwest, put it there first,
then all around us,
but real close.
So for those people that don't
understand what this means,
when you're on the ground
calling for fire, it's, it's,
and I've talked about a lot of fracture
side and blue on blue situations. I've,
I had him on my deployment and it's a,
it's a very scary thing and it's even
scarier from the air to the ground.
It's, it's, it's hard for
people to understand this.
When you're in an aircraft,
it's very hard to see what's
happening on the ground.
It can be very easy to get confused and
so it's hard to bring fire very close to
your position unless you are
just in a terrible situation.
And so when you get a call that saying,
put the fire all around us as
close as you can. You know,
this is a desperate scenario
and so I'll go back to the book,
Roger Dusty, we've got them after
a number of Cobra attack runs,
Duffy called Panther lead. This is dusty
Sinai, so that's the guy on the ground.
That's his call sign.
Dusty cyanide,
you've broken the enemy attack for
now hundreds of bodies in the wire,
maybe a thousand but we cannot
hold after a short break.
He continued. We are leaving Firebase,
Charlie, now stop them from following us.
Whatever it takes, put your stuff
right on top of the fire base.
Now
and again,
this is something that it,
just
to explain what that means.
If you don't understand what that
you'd never in the military to explain,
you're calling for people to drop fire
onto your own position so that you can
get away. It doesn't get any, there's
nothing. It doesn't get any more intense.
It doesn't get any more dramatic.
It doesn't get any more
sketchy than that right there.
That was one hell of a fight.
And John Joseph Duffy was the adviser,
the American advisor on the ground.
And he is a true American hero Army
Special Forces officer had those adviser
duties. Uh, that battle, the
battle lasted for about two weeks.
The climax of it was a couple
days with that last night.
That is described in the
book, uh, out of a 470 man,
south Vietnamese airborne Paratroop
Battalion. At the end of that fight,
the next morning, uh,
the American advisor,
John Joseph Duffy and 36 of the South
Vietnamese were all that survived to be
picked up. Uh, when they, when
they got off of that Firebase and,
and John was a wounded five
times in the battle. So yeah,
470 man battalion, 36 survivors and
their, and their wounded American advisor.
Absolutely unbelievable.
And I know you wrote in here that major
Duffy was recommended for the medal of
honor and he got the distinguished
service cross for his actions,
which if you don't know what that is,
it's,
it's the second highest award
underneath the metal of honor.
Yeah. And you actually talk about possibly
writing about that battle. That's my,
that's my next project. And in
doing this book, and there's a, uh,
there's a statement at the beginning of
the book that I wrote this some 40 years
after I experienced
these actions. Uh, and,
and some things were still
perfectly clear in my mind.
Other things were a little bit hazier
than I thought they would be when I put
pen to paper. Uh, so in
the process of writing,
I not only just dug down in my mind and
relived every experience as detailed as
I could to get everything correct.
I contacted those who were also
involved in and the actions to get their
versions of their view,
their recollections,
to be sure I had this as right as I could.
Uh,
John Joseph Duffy was one that I got
ahold of major Duffy. I had never met him.
I'd never talked to him since that
battle until I was able to track him down
with the wonders of modern
communication and Internet. Uh, and,
and in sharing the details about that
fight, uh, he dropped a couple of hints.
He said,
you know,
somebody really ought to write the history
of the battle of Firebase. Charlie,
this is one of the most extraordinary
fights in the entire Vietnam war.
So I think it was after about half a
dozen times he said, I said, okay, John,
I'll do it. I'll write
it. So yes, right now I'm,
I'm working on doing my research
and getting everything in order to,
to write the story of, of, of that
battle and more detail than I give on my,
what couple of pages are in my
book. Yeah, that's one of the,
one of the most interesting things for
me about doing this podcast. And we're,
again, another thing we were talking
about is there's so many, you know,
I didn't know about that battle and
I'm a pretty decent student of military
history.
I didn't know about that battle and
didn't know about major John Duffy.
I absolutely should.
And we
all should.
Any and what you realize
is that battle that man,
we will never be able to account
for all of these heroes. No,
you just can't do it.
So
again,
this is fast forwarding a little bit
through the book. And by the way,
I didn't mention the name of the
book yet. Oh yeah. Thank you.
The name of the book
is through the valley,
my captivity in Vietnam
by William Reader and
get this book.
So at this point I'm,
I'm jumping ahead a little bit too,
a situation where you've got,
and I'll go to the book tanks in the wire
at Poli cling launched now and call me
and wrote for their radio freak
hawks claw will get up later.
You'll be covering him too.
You have tail number,
zero five three and six eight to go.
So that right there is something bad
is happening and you got to go now.
And what's, what's interesting,
and I'll point this out for again,
people that aren't in the military,
by the way,
a lot of guys that listen to this or in
the military, a lot of law enforcement,
but there's a lot of civilians that don't
know everything that I'm talking about
or that word that you're talking about.
So what I like about this is
that what they're telling,
what they're telling the colonel
to do is launch your aircraft.
Just go get an aircraft and launch
and start heading in that direction.
We'll give you a frequency
when you get up there,
we'll tell you what's going to happen
once you get up there to go. So again,
this is an inextremist situation.
What we would do that would be similar
to this in the seal teams is we would go
on QRF missions, quick reaction
forces where they would call it there.
It happened to me where
they call up and say, hey,
something's going on here at this
location. Go and I'd say, who's the unit?
We don't know yet. Any frequency.
What's what radio frequency on?
We don't know yet. We'll
get it to you. Launch.
We'd get in our vehicles and launch.
Yeah.
You developed the situation and route and
then when you lay eyes on when you get
there and start talking to the folks.
Yep, exactly. Back to the book,
I stuffed a small emergency radio into
one of the pockets of my survival vest.
No time to perform the
normal check on the radio. I,
I had to include that. There's a lesson
learned there. I had to include that.
It's, you know, the
radio will always work.
If you test it in the water tight, you
don't test it is the one time that locker.
Yeah, that's the lesson. Check all
your survival, your shirts in order,
regardless of how hot that mission is.
Um,
now you're heading to a place called
the Ben hit and I'm going to the book.
We headed to Ben hat as we
crossed the last ridge line.
The entire valley before
us was filled with smoke.
Tracers streamed outward from defensive
positions inside the camp enemy tracers
replied from outside to jet.
Fighters bombed next to the camp.
Nva rockets,
artillery and mortars
exploded in the camp.
Enemy tanks breached the perimeter one
inside and part way up the hill look like
it had been killed already.
I couldn't be sure an AC one 30 on air
force AC when 30 spectre gunship was
leaving.
He had worked the area over with 20
millimeter Volk Vulcan Gatling guns and 40
millimeter cannon cannon's
probably hitting the tank
enemy infantry move through
openings in the jungle canopy. I could
see groups assembling to join the attack.
Yeah, it was, it was one heck
of a heck of a battle. The,
this whole situation we're getting to
in the book occurred during the Easter
offensive of 1972 when I arrived back
in Vietnam at the end of [inaudible] 71,
it seemed like the war was over.
In fact,
I was afraid that maybe I'd missed my
chance for combat and a Cobra because
things were so quiet. Uh,
many American, in fact,
most American forces had been withdrawn
in the central part of Vietnam.
The central highlands
where I was operating,
there were no American
ground forces left at all.
It's just some special forces guys,
uh,
army aviation units and some
air force unit. That was it. Um,
how that changed as we got into the
spring of 1972 because the enemy had been
building up their divisions across
the border into Laos and Cambodia.
And in the spring of 72,
they launched an attack
from the demilitarized zone
and attack from Cambodia
towards Saigon.
And then finally in April,
attacks across the central
highlands where we were,
and there were a lot of enemy this day
at Ben Het courses is going to turn into
the the day, the day that we're
getting to here. Uh, but yeah,
elements of two north Vietnamese
divisions with artillery,
with anti aircraft weapons Galore.
Uh, and with, uh, with armor, uh,
going into the end of the camp. And there
we showed up with our two cobras to do,
do what we could do. Was that your
first time seeing armor enemy armor? No.
Uh, that, that, that
period was on the 20 foot,
cause this is the 9th of May. On the 24th
of April, the enemy attacked the, uh,
the 22nd Arvin that's Army Vietnam
Division headquarters at 10 can,
which is a little bit further to the east
from Ben hit. So on the 24th of April,
they attack Tan cannon and defeated and
overran that Nva division, uh, with a,
a number of tanks. So that was the
first time I saw tanks and battle.
Then we come out on the 9th of
May and I'm seeing tanks again.
Whole different ballgame for the
guys on the ground. Yes. Yeah.
This guerrilla war suddenly turned into
a very conventional war fighting regular
north Vietnamese divisions.
Now
it's again you,
you had some time on station,
you did a bunch of shooting and running
and gun and you had to go back to reload,
refuel, and I'm going back to the
book now. On our way back to Ben hat,
we could see the battle continuing
at ploy polyclinic, Holly clang,
Vietnamese air force a one sky
Raiders dove dropping bombs.
We pass close enough to see one as it
trailed smoke and flame and went into the
ground and awful explosion.
I saw parachute and a mayday call came
over the radio emergency radio frequency.
I called headquarters to tell them I
was diverting for a few minutes to help
cover the downed v. N a. F.
So the Vietnamese air force
pilot negative panther,
three six permission denied.
Proceed direct to Ben hat out.
You try it again.
Same results.
So you saw the north or a South
Vietnamese air force pilot gets shot down.
Right. And you call back to base and
say, I'm going to go cover for this guy.
When they try and rescue them
and they tell you no right
now.
So you do what you're told.
Yeah. Decisions have kind of bad. I mean,
and there's pluses and minuses to that.
There. There were guys on the ground at
Ben Hat in serious trouble at Ben hit.
There were two Vietnamese
ranger battalions,
so probably four or
500 people at the most,
probably for 400 people on the ground
at Ben hit with two American advisors.
There's two Americans on the ground.
They are under attack by elements
of two north Vietnamese divisions,
which means thousands of infantry
with the tanks and artillery,
everything attack. And so yeah,
they were in dire straights though.
I really had hoped we could briefly
stop over and help get this uh, Vietnam,
Vietnamese air force pilot.
It's picked up. Yeah, no, that's a tough
decision for command to make. Right.
But from my position, I
look at it like, okay,
the command has a better overall
view of the battlefield right now.
And if they're telling me to
proceed on to Ben Hat. Got It.
Even though you obviously,
yes,
you have a little good.
I'm glad you have that perspective because
I didn't know that at the time at all.
Yeah. Well it's easy for me
right now sitting in an air
conditioned space with my
headset on. Yeah. Um, so
much in Vietnam, you know,
and warfare is different today and I think
things are probably much more planned
out and, and, and you go to a,
according to a set of rules and
procedures more than we did,
so many of these combat missions with
Cobras and Vietnam and that day and age,
we would get launched out of our base
and we'd go out and make contact with
people.
And it was pretty much up to the pilot
and command or the air mission commander,
uh, to decide where he would go and how
he would support and what was the hottest
fire on town that, that needed
help. Uh, so we always had,
some of it was just I guess
are pompous attitude too.
We always felt we had a better handle on
what was happening then the guys in the
headquarters that made some
of those decisions. Uh,
in fact when we first saw tanks,
uh,
in the area before that battle
at tank can on the 24th of April,
we saw tanks and reported them back
through headquarters and there was a great
deal of reluctance on the part of anybody
in the headquarter staff to do believe
that there were tanks. Uh,
there was a guy that, in fact,
this is another interesting
situation at Vietnam at that time,
the senior commander in two core,
that area that I was
operating in was not a guy.
There was a civilian named John Paul van
and Mr van made all the decisions now
to keep things illegal. He had a two star
army general officer working for him.
So all military orders came
through the army general.
But Mr van was making
the decisions and the,
and when we reported we had
seen tanks in mid to mid April.
Van Said, Nah, there's not tanks
that I fly out there all the time.
If there are tanks,
I'd have seen him.
He said what you guys saw our probably
elephants in the jungle. Uh, so that's,
that's what we dealt with with
uh, with our headquarters.
Yeah, that's interesting.
They're definitely was when I was in Iraq,
there is very tight control over air to
ground support, especially in the cities.
In Ramadi. It was very difficult to get
dropped, bombs dropped. But you know,
who had really good decentralized command
was the tanks and the tanks that we
work with,
they would,
they would come and they had pretty good
control over what I'm talking to tank
commander,
at least at the company command level.
We had some company commanders that
would just get after it and they would,
would make stuff happen.
So we felt really comfortable
working with the tankers and in,
they supported us over and over and
over again. Really, like I said,
with a lot of decentralized command, you
know, they couldn't, they had to use some,
they obviously use discretion,
but they had a lot of authority out there,
which was, which was great for us, which
we did as well, which was really good.
So at already, yeah, you
left me. I'm going back from,
we'd rearm refueled or costume.
We're heading back up,
were denied permission to deviate
over to Polly clang. And, uh, we're,
we're getting back into it.
Have been at one more time.
And now what you're doing when I'm
going to pick the story back up here,
there's a Huey that's got resupply.
So he's got, you know, bullets,
probably bullets, water and food
maybe at this point, just bullets.
And they need to get that gear down
to the guys on the ground. Right.
The guys on the ground, the base had
been pretty much completely overrun.
The friendliest had consolidated in a
command bunker complex or defensive Duggin
positions at the top of the hill, which
was their Firebase. Uh, they were,
when we got the call to cover that Huey,
uh,
we were told that the guys on the ground,
we're completely out of anti tank ammo
and we're almost out of small arms
ammunition and could we cover this?
You in for the resupply. So here we go.
Back to the book. The Huey came into
a low hover near the command bunker.
The crew kicked out the ammo boxes.
The helicopter did a
hovering turn and took off.
I began a sharp left turn
so I could continue shooting
suppressive fire for him.
The enemy opened up on our two Cobiz with
everything they had my view left right
and above and below was
filled with tracers.
Tim fired continuously and Tim was your
was him was Tim was my front seat or my
copilot gunner in the front seat working
that knows to her while I was firing
rockets. Tim fired continuously
on those firing at us.
We took large caliber hits
all over the aircraft.
50 ones like I talked about and
14.5 millimeter rounds came through.
The cockpit
hits from small arms,
always felt something like
Jiffy pop popcorn popping
against it's tin foil cover.
These seem like Jack Hammers slamming
into the aircraft beginning in the rear,
working up the side and
then into the cockpit.
The tail rotor were shot off
and the engine was shot up.
Every system on the helicopter was damaged
in some way without the tail rotor.
The aircraft began to spin.
Fuel lines ruptured and we were burning.
I keyed the microphone.
This is three six taking fire from
four o'clock taking fire everywhere,
taking fire, taking hits, going down,
panther going down the engine
quit the rotor. RPM caution.
Light flashed.
The audio warning sounded announcing
got my rotor blades were turning
dangerously slow.
I slammed the collective down hard to
auto rotate under optimal conditions.
This is a controlled emergency descent.
Under these conditions,
I could only hope to lessen
the severity of the crash.
We corkscrewed down in flames.
As I wrestled the aircraft,
I radioed my wing man flame,
you better get in here and get us
out quick. There was no answer.
They were fighting for their lives.
I learned years later that
when I called taking hits,
flame had banked his cobra
and fired rockets onto the
position shooting at me as
he did.
So a big ugly 51 round came through the
cockpit and tore into his chest high on
the left side.
Bob took the controls and headed for help.
Flying from the front seat, microbrew
came down, spinning and burning.
It hit the ground hard,
nose low on the left side.
It bounced back into the air,
spun another turn and a half and crashed.
It's settled nearly upright,
firing Gulf, the cockpit.
So
pilots are known for maintaining
their composure. Right. And I, I've,
I've heard pilots do it and clearly, you
know, you're saying we're taking hits,
we're taking fire from everywhere. We're
going down path. They're going down.
Okay.
Are you so tracking on controlling
the aircraft that you're,
you're just completely focused on that,
that the rest of what's happening
is a little bit blocked out or what?
Okay.
Are you thinking yourself,
I've got to survive this crash?
Are you not worried about the fact
that when you get on the ground, hey,
now I'm going to,
we're going to
be surrounded by enemy. Yeah, no,
none of those thoughts are taking place.
As I said in an earlier
thing that you read,
everyone who's not totally
insane is scared and combat, uh,
off times. That fear, uh,
comes about after the missions
are over at the end of the day,
when you think back on what
she'd been through that day,
thank goodness we got to
drink alcohol at Vietnam.
I don't know how people survive
in war today. I really don't.
We've got drunk every single night and
then went back out the next day and did
it again.
So there's fear at the end of the day,
there's also fear and trepidation,
uh,
to a degree when you first go,
like when I described coming across the
hill and seeing what that battle of Ben
had looked like, tracer stuff
all over the place. I mean,
you get butterflies in your
stomach and you're anxious,
but once you go in on that
mission and start those gun runs,
it's all, there's,
there's, there's no time.
There's no mental space for
any of that other thought.
There was no mental space for that fear.
Uh,
you just focus on what you have to do
and you do it. Uh, and the pull thing,
we just ready to get in the
shot down though still. I
mean, all these years later,
I'm sitting here with a red emotional
flush and my face reliving this yet,
one more time. But no, I don't,
I don't recall thinking of
anything in those moments.
But, but doing that mission,
controlling that aircraft,
dealing with that emergency
situation as best I could and,
and going through the whole process,
I don't even think there was a thought
of life or death or who am I going to
make it or not make it or none of
that was even there. It was, it's,
you do what you have to do and,
and get it done.
And then when it all settled in and,
and, and uh, you know, hit spun,
settled in,
crashed smoke and flames everywhere the
thing begins exploding a then even then
there's not time for that fear factor
then because then you start dealing with,
okay, what do I have to do now to
survive this and get out of here?
And so your aircraft's on fire and I
guess you're not sitting around pondering
much when your aircraft is on fire and
you're stuck and they're trying to get
out. You get hung up while you're
getting now by the way. I did.
So you,
you do get out. You make it away
from the bird a little bit and
ew.
Ew.
Ended up getting some distance away.
You lost, you lost your wing man. Right?
Or he started, you lost
your, your um, yeah my,
my wing man took the 51 wing
minutes, took the 51, but Tim,
he got out of the aircraft too
and took off in another direction.
Now my front seat,
Tim Conroy in a Cobra, the, there's
two canopies, one for the front seat,
one for the back,
the front seat canopy opens to the left.
The backseat canopy opens to
the right. Uh, so we, we hit,
we had an inner calm conversation.
I said, uh, I don't know. I said,
let's get out of this thing. That's,
that's good enough for that. And he,
Roger that call and uh, and then he
got out his way. I got out my way.
I Dunno if you had that little vignette
of what happened when I was hanging
upside down out there.
The
aircraft. Yeah. That guy was New
England to mark mark true hand.
The idea of advisor on the ground there.
I'll, I'll, I'll go ahead and if you want.
Yeah. Inside Ben hat, one
of the American advisors,
Mark True Hand Watch this get shot down
and crash. He saw Tim exit the aircraft.
He saw me hanging out of the side
of the Cobra head down with my feet,
stuck in the cockpit,
the helicopter burning.
He'd seen a truck driver die in agony
in a blazing semi rack years before and
it's,
he would not
let that happen again.
He raised the sight of his m 16 rifle
to my body as he began to squeeze the
trigger to put me out of my misery,
a cloud of smoke billowed
from the exploding aircraft.
It obscured me from his view. When
the smoke cleared, I was gone.
And that's something that you
found out years later? Yeah,
he got in touch with me. I got
it. He contacted me and said,
I think it was a letter and said I was
one of the advisors on the ground had
been hit when he got shot down.
I can give you some information about
what happened if you'd like to hear it,
if you don't, I understand if you just
don't want to even go there. I said, no.
Tell me what you know. So he shared
that story with me on believable. Yeah.
Okay. So I'm going back to
the book. You're, you're,
this is the state you're in. The pain
in my back was intense. It was broken.
The fire had burned the back of my neck.
I had lesser burns on my face.
My hair was singed. I had pulled
a shell fragment out of my ankle.
Superficial lacerations covered my
face and forehead bleeding badly.
I was a mess, but I was
motivated. I wanted to get away.
I staggered from the crash site and
headed southeast towards contem con tomb
costume as it was getting dark.
I had not gone far.
When I heard helicopters approaching
cobras came in low shooting and you had
your little a strobe and so here we go.
I held the light over my head,
pointed it toward the aircraft.
It flashed a few times.
The gunner in the lead Cobra opened up
on me with this mini gun. A streamer.
Tracers came right at me,
which is,
this is something we we learned in Iraq
as well. When you fire off a strobe,
if someone isn't expecting
or isn't looking for it,
it just looks like muzzle flashing.
Anybody that sees it will shoot at it.
We had blue covers that we put on them
that supposedly change the color of it so
it wouldn't look like enemy
fire. But no. In fact,
I ran into that a front
seat or that opened up on my
years later at Bentley Hill
and a yeah, he shared, he said, yeah,
we were out there flying that mission
and it sure look like enemy fire.
Sorry about that.
So here we go. Back to the booker. This
is a little bit about your attitude.
I was cocksure if anyone can survive this.
It was me.
I'd been a boy scout though I was one
of the trouble makers in my troop.
I've learned a lot.
I backpacked 65 miles
through the mountains in five
days and practice survival
skills. My troubled youth got me
suspended from school a number of times,
but it also taught me lessons. I learned
a street fight, take care of myself.
I had boxed, played football and
run track. I majored in forestry,
worked cattle ranches,
rode broncs in small Rodeos,
fought forest fires,
worked construction,
and was an electrical lineman
for southern California Edison.
I remembered a little ditty
my mother had taught me.
The Lord helps those who help themselves.
I knew I could depend on its absolute
truth to get me through this.
The lowered hell helps those who help
themselves. God, I'll do that. Do all,
I can muster every bit of what's
inside me. I'll do my part,
I'll do all I can to help myself.
So please,
please do yours.
I need your help.
I said it again to myself.
Drawing comfort and strength.
The Lord helps those who helps themselves.
I would repeat it often as I set my
mind to doing all I must to survive.
Yeah.
This is a, this is interesting
going through this at all,
this detail again because when I,
when I wrote the book,
I had to revisit everything in detail.
Like I had not done
since it happened to me.
I had never gone to this depth of
reliving those experiences. Um,
yeah. And it, uh, it's tough
to think back on that. Um,
indeed,
when I was writing this,
I'd share some of the writing with my
wife when I come to bed late at night.
And after I got a few chapters into this,
I told her when I said, Melanie, what am,
what am I doing? This whole thing is
a series of unfortunate events, uh,
who's gonna want to read something like
this? And, uh, she told me, so bill,
I know the whole story. She said,
stick with it, finish this book.
Because I think that in it, uh,
there's, there's inspiration,
there's motivation for, for people. It's
not just your story, it can help others.
Uh, and so in that vein, I mean,
I say that because it is getting a little
emotional as we read through this and
that's fine. But I do hope that some of
this is useful and helpful for others.
And, uh, I grew up going
to church as a kid,
but I wasn't overly overly
religious guy. And, uh,
somewhere around college I could go
into church altogether and in the army,
the only time I can remember that I've
been going to church was from memorial
services for guys. And
that was about it. Uh,
but if you end up in a situation like
this or, or I would say any really,
if you think the situation in your life
is stressful and is about to overwhelm
you, uh, you need some help
beyond yourself. And, uh,
you know, no matter what you,
and I'm not selling any religion,
but I would say whatever your
religious beliefs are, uh,
you can find a lot of strength
and your God and, uh, get,
get close to God and he'll help
you through it. And he certainly,
I couldn't have done this by myself.
I,
I grabbed a hold of that
duty that my mom gave me.
I also grabbed a hold of the 23rd psalm
and when stuff got really close to being
blown to smithereens a few
times later on in my captivity,
that 23rd psalm was going over and over
again in my mind too. So yeah, again,
not selling any religion, but whatever
your spirituality is your best.
Get comfortable with it if you're
going to be in dire straits like this.
Yeah. And it's, it's, it's interesting
that you're, you're saying, look,
I'm going to do everything I
can, but I'm need some. Yep. Yep.
And you know, certainly, you know, when
you, when you say that other people,
you know, we'll be able to find,
absolutely. I mean, just me reading this,
I've found all kinds of, not just
inspiration but practical guidance, which,
you know, one of the things you just
said is practical guidance on, you know,
someone that's been through
what you've been through.
There's so much that everybody else
can take away and learn from and yeah,
that's,
that's one of them right there.
Do what you can do everything that you
can and then have some faith on the
things that you can't control
are going to work out your way.
Yeah. And I think that's important too,
because I'm thinking now as we're talking,
and I don't know if we're going
to get to that specific part in,
in the book or not. Uh,
but early on, I want to,
I think it was the first night I got beef,
52 strikes almost landing on top of me.
And I'm beginning to feel that,
am I going to survive this or not?
And I think the answer is I don't know.
But in that answer is,
I don't know. And so what I mean
that, that, that doesn't matter.
That's not important. I may
survive. I may not survive.
I'm going to do all I can to survive.
So I got to the point where this fear of
being blown to smithereens kind of went
away. Uh, and I just settled into,
I'll either survive or I won't survive.
It's not, I can't worry about that.
All I can worry about is what can I do
to try and set the best conditions to
make that survival possible. And,
uh, I either will or I won't.
Yeah. One of the similar thing that I
always felt was, you know, when I rack,
one of the biggest threats
to us was iads and you,
they're random. They're going to hit
you or they're not going to hit you.
And when you, every time you
go outside the wire, there's,
there's a chance that it's your day.
And you know,
kind of what I told my guys and
the way I felt myself was, okay,
I know they're out there, we've done
everything we can to mitigate the risk.
We've done our planning, we'd done our
drills, we've gathered our intelligence,
there's nothing else we can do to control
it. So I'm not going to worry about it.
Right. And I've done everything
I can. Like you said, I've,
I've helped him at
myself as much as I can.
And then after that it's out of my hands.
And in the more you worry about it,
like you said, well it does.
It does. It really matter.
I can sit here and worry
about it, but doesn't matter.
Got It. Got To move forward.
Exactly.
Here's you,
you do a couple of days,
three days worth of evasion of the
enemy and now you're out hiding.
You hear some voices, you crouch down
your hide, you know their people.
And here we go back to the book.
A lot of crashing around came
from the direction of the voices.
I looked up and saw a uniformed NVA
soldiers pointing AK 47 rifles at my head.
They Shriek, something in motion for
me to stand up. I did. I was captured.
I felt indescribably sick in the pit
of my stomach as the world fell away,
I'd been struggling for three days to
stay alive. I was in miserable shape,
but I had been free and I had options.
No more.
My soul was a washed with anguish.
I was no longer a free man.
In that instant, I'd become a captive
of the communist North Vietnamese army,
a prisoner of war,
another American POW in
the long Vietnam conflict.
I had no idea how long they might
let me live or if I was about to die.
A couple of them were shaking.
We stood in utter silence for a moment.
They glared at me.
I glared at them for that tense instant.
I didn't know if I'd be riddled
with bullets or be allowed to live.
One barked something at me.
I could not understand
another joint in than a third.
I looked right into their eyes.
I was an American.
I would show them the best
American fighting man that I could
in the pitiful state that
I was in. Um, you know,
that that's the best I could do
on describing capture it. It's,
it's impossible to really convey the
full feeling of losing your freedom and
being a captive. It's just
indescribable. Uh, but I, I did the,
uh, the best that a, that I could,
I was in miserable shape. I mean,
you read about the wounds that
I had. Uh, in addition to those,
I picked up some Leeches, uh, that
I've been plucking off on my body.
Uh, my, my face was covered with blood.
My three day growth, the heavy beard was,
was sticking through, uh, because
of my back injuries that a,
I didn't even know that I got released
and I had badly broken my back. Uh,
I had no control of my bowels or bladder
for those three days, so I smelled.
I was just an awful mess. When those guys
captured me and took me up that hill,
they finally get you
to sort of like a camp,
sort of the first interrogation camper.
Yeah.
Yeah. What were the, I mean the
capture me, the jumbo so thick,
they were only a few yards away when I
stumbled upon them and then they, uh,
and they had been down a
stream filling canteens.
These five young guys at captured me and
they took me almost an equal distant up
a hill opposite and I
came into an open area,
still had the canopy of the triple canopy
jungle. Uh, but the bottom was all open.
There are hundreds of north Vietnamese
soldiers supplies defensive positions.
This was a major staging area
for this battle is taking place.
And as I was trying to get away from,
from the battle and get towards costume,
I stumbled right into there
staging area
and you start getting your,
you know,
start getting the soft interrogation
is what I put down here. A guy says,
you know, we found pictures of a pretty
later lady with your or your wallet,
obviously your family and you say,
yeah,
I know you miss them and are very worried
and they are very worried about you.
You follow the rules and
you will be home soon,
you'll receive humane and lenient
treatment, you will be allowed to go home.
And I put that in there cause that's a
refrain that we hear quite a bit humane
and leads.
That was, that was a refrain.
They would say it all the time.
And during my whole
captivity. Yeah, you do,
you do what you're supposed
to do and cooperate.
You get the humane and lenient treatment.
Of course you
warrant fully cooperative at all with
them and what they're asking you.
So they're there.
They went from that idea.
So they start stepping it
up on you and you know,
here's an example of the things that they
say do you are a war criminal and the
Geneva Geneva agreements do not
apply to you. You have no rights.
But we will still give you the
deserved humane and lenient treatment.
All you have to do is cooperate with us
and acknowledge your crimes. Yep, Yep.
Yeah.
That goes back to your reading of the
code of conduct that started this off to
our code of conduct was
different. Uh, said we are,
we are bound to give only our name, rank,
service number and date of birth and,
and the, and the way that was
taught and the way we understood it,
that was all we could give was name,
rank, service number, date of birth.
And if we gave anything
else, uh, we had uh,
we had caved in and we're cooperating
with the enemy. Uh, so that was my stance.
That was all I was going to give them
was my name, rank, service number,
date of birth. Uh, you may get into some
of the things that that took place. Uh,
I would just like to comment that there
was nothing heroic going on at all.
I guess a couple things
that were going on.
I was trying to abide by the code of
conduct and I was in a state where I had
been near death for days,
was very near death at that moment.
And was numb and just almost didn't care.
It's hard to understand and believe,
but almost didn't care at that point.
And then I got so angry and aggravated
with this son of a bitch that ended up
being my interrogator from his
initial soft sell, as you said, but,
but his first words,
he showed up,
he was only guy had spoken
English since I was captured,
started asked me about myself
by condition if I was hurt.
And so I opened up with
him about some of that.
But then when he got into what was clearly
a, an interrogation than I clammed up,
uh, W I would close these
comments now with, uh,
the fact that he didn't break
me in. That interrogation, uh,
speaks nothing to my heroism or
ability to resist interrogation.
Anyone can be broken. Uh, and if this
would have continued over time, uh,
you know, I'm, I'm sure that he could
have gotten me to do something, uh,
with his brutality.
Probably nothing that would have
given him any useful intelligence,
but he might've got made to
do, to do something. Yeah.
So I was for that. For that,
those moments on those days
or that initial interrogation,
I was able to stick with my name, rank,
service number, date of birth. Awesome.
Here,
here's an example of that is
back to the book here.
Please sign this.
He handed me one of the sheets of
paper and a pen. I looked at the paper.
It was typed in English.
As I began to read the words,
my interrogator interrupted.
This is simply a form that acknowledges
your status we needed so we can begin to
process you for release so we can send
word to your family of your status.
Please. Just signed. I read the words.
I could not believe what I was reading.
There was a blank fates place
for me to fill in my name.
The tech said that I was an American
war criminal who had been conducting an
illegal acts against the Vietnamese
people, including biocide,
genocide and eco side. I had dropped
fire bombs and chemical bombs.
I'd killed old men,
pregnant women and babies.
Biocide genocide, Eco
side. What a bunch of crap.
I raised my head and looked into his eyes.
No,
I will not sign this there.
I had spoken, you must.
I will not.
His agitation return now you must.
I glared at him. He got up and came at me.
He smacked me across the face. You must.
He turned to his sidekick
and spoke quietly and the
man got up at his direction.
Two Guards dragged me up against
a tree abroad trunk of a tree.
I've been bent over since the crash,
unable to stand erect.
They forced me up into a straight
sitting position and tied me to the tree.
It hurt like hell. I couldn't keep
my face from contorting in anguish.
Now you signed no more orders.
They pulled on the ropes to bring
my arms closer together behind me.
The pain in my back. Increased new pain
was introduced in my shoulder joints.
More demands to sign more refusals.
The ropes tightened further.
They move my elbows closer together.
More demands more refusals,
ropes ever tighter,
more pain.
I was uncontrollably
grimacing and cursing.
I would not sign.
I could never consider
signing anything like that.
The brutality made me angrier and
more firmly set against giving in.
I could have been broken and made
design eventually. There's no doubt.
No Man can resist forever,
but this interrogator would
not bring me to breaking point.
On that day,
his demands continued
and so did my refusals.
The ropes tightened more and
more pain scream through me.
My anger swelled against this asshole.
I began grunting in audible attack against
the agony the guards gave the ropes.
One huge last poll, which brought
my elbows together behind me.
I felt a pop as each shoulder.
Dislocated pain shot through my torso,
up my neck,
into my head and down my back,
through my groin and into my thighs.
I've never felt such pain.
My vision narrowed and I passed out.
Sign.
I could only grown and shake my head.
The interrogators scowled
angrily turned and left.
We're to continue on.
Okay,
this is a little bit further on and
he's saying that he's given you one last
chance to sign this paper and
one last chance to cooperate.
Will you?
Going back to the book now my head hung
down partly and exhaustion and partly in
an intentional rudeness,
not paying him any attention.
I looked up when he finished,
I saw his sadistic minion standing a few
yards in front of me holding an AK 47
at the ready.
Your last chance?
Yeah.
The assistant raised the
rifle and pointed it at me.
I stared ahead and said nothing.
No heroism was involved.
I was rung out at the end
of everything I had to give.
I had been so close to death for so long,
was so angry and so absolutely drained.
A faint spark was all I had left.
I felt numb,
detached from what was happening.
I was not resisting.
I was just giving into the flow
of whatever was destined to be.
That might be deaf.
It might not.
I had seen army training film at army
training film years before showing the
mock execution of a Korean War POW.
I remembered that scene.
The action of the trigger being pulled,
went over and over in my
mind. Click, click, Click Ben.
I flinched as a soldier, jerk the
trigger back, but nothing happened.
No shot,
no loud bang,
no bullet ripping my scholar chest,
nothing.
The soldier laughed.
My interrogator smiled.
I am done with you.
You will be taken away from here.
Yeah,
that was three days of,
yeah,
there's three horrible days losing my
freedom, going through that interrogation,
um,
being thrown down into a pit
at night is where I stayed.
It was one of their old abandoned bunkers.
We had about six inches of mud
and Goo in the bottom and uh,
Eh, and that caused me a big psychological
issue that first night closed in that
darkness that night.
Uh,
I really had to fight to just keep
my cool down there with a bunch of,
there were centipedes and spiders
and rats and it was, it was a mess.
I'd spend the nights down there and
come up in the daytime for interrogation
back down in that whole night's
backup for interrogation.
So what we read cover to pray to three
days before he finally gave up on me and
yeah, I had no idea what was
going to happen. I just, and
even thinking back on it,
it's just going through all that
pretty much and just a numb state,
um, with, with, with that treatment. Yeah.
My shoulders today still
caused me problems.
I had a son that ended up playing
football for University of Washington many
years ago. He's going to
turn 50 years, uh, in April.
So this was a number of years
ago. But yeah, in high school,
like I throw about two passes and that
was it for my shoulders can't play.
You can't play horseshoes or anything,
but uh,
yeah.
You know,
so it's something that
definitely I've experienced.
So doing these readings,
and I've talked about it before,
that, you know, when I read
something in my head and it kind of,
I go all of that,
that's powerful.
But then when you read it aloud
and you hear it, it's just,
it's even more, and it's the
same thing with, you know,
I know I sent you Jody medics, the
podcast with Jody medical was on. Yeah.
And he said the same thing. He, you
know, he said to me, he said, you know,
when you're reading it,
it's like,
it's like I'm hearing my own thoughts
or something. You know, it just, right.
It just, it brought him back
and yeah, there's something,
there's something about that. It's
okay. It's like when it's, when it's,
when you're reading it,
it's sort of detached from reality or
it's one step further detached from
reality.
And,
and obviously sitting in
with Jodie sitting here with
you and knowing that this
is you,
you know,
one point that I make all the time
when I covered these historical books,
I always remind people that, cause
you know, people in this day and age,
we're used to seeing movies.
We're used to seeing, watching TV.
And I always say that this guy that I'm
talking about, this is a person, you know,
this guy in World War II, this is a
person, this guy in world war one,
this is a man and sort of have you
sitting here knowing that this is you.
It's, it's, I don't even know
what to say to describe it.
Well thanks Jack O and this, this has
become an emotional experience for me,
but it's important and I think this
is going to be an important podcast.
I wrote that book. I finished
it. It was published last April.
Yeah.
I've not read that book
since it was published. Uh,
I mean it was something to go through and
relive all that to get it written. And,
uh, and so it's been
almost a year. I haven't,
I haven't read the book so we're going
into, into, into detail. But, uh, this is,
this is good.
So
do you get turned over to some other,
some other guards?
Bright and they start
taking you on a walk.
You're walking to somewhere
else in urine. I, you know,
you talked about the conditioner.
You, by the way, you have a broken,
crushed vertebrae at this point,
so badly, badly broken back. Uh,
yeah. Vertebrae is about completely
crush damage to two other verbiage.
Your leg swollen and you got all
kinds of shoe and now you're,
now you've got to walk. And so I'm
going out with know that. Yeah,
they gave me my boots back after those
three days. Materialization, no socks,
no laces. Boots. Bare
feet. Okay, go ahead.
We had a old Vietnam seal when I got to
seal team one in 1990 and he would run
barefoot all the time.
And you know, one day was,
hey, hey sir, why you, you know,
why you run barefoot? And he says,
the first thing that goofs do, you take
your shoes, got to have a hard feat.
I was like, okay, I guess I'm
running barefoot now. I was thinking,
because when I showed up at CLT one,
I always joke about this,
I thought I was going to the Vietnam
War in 1991 when I got there, I thought,
I'm going to Vietnam now. You
know, I was that how you were?
But I was a little off,
you know, historically.
So that's the situation you're in.
Going back to the book,
they'd been saying a phrase.
So as you're marching with these guys,
they've been saying a phrase for the
past two days that I couldn't understand.
I thought it was Vietnamese Gacaca die.
As we pushed up the road,
they walked behind me poking their
rifle barrels into my kidneys,
my ribs shouting with increasing urgency,
go cook with [inaudible].
And then after a while, for the first
time, I understood what they were saying,
go quick or die. They had been
taught one short phrase in English.
It was all they knew and
they had pronounced it so
poorly that it took me two
days to figure it out.
I moved as fast as I could,
but I was at the end of everything I had.
I struggled on and you don't.
I'm just noticing this.
You're going to reach the end of
everything you've had. I mean,
you already were there many times.
You're going to reach the again,
you just reached it. It's, it's
okay.
Incredible.
It's an amazing thing about human beings.
What we have inside that we can
dig down and grab a hold of one.
We have two that we don't think
we ever could have done it,
but it's there and here is
something that helps you.
Back to the book.
I found myself mentally reciting what
I could recall of the 23rd psalm.
I repeated one line over
and over in my head.
Yea though I walk through the
Valley of the shadow of death,
I will fear no evil for thou art with me.
That wasn't the only time during my
captivity that the 23rd psalm came to my
lips.
Nope.
Okay.
After it in,
please forgive me for like I already
covered three days of misery.
Now we're talking about,
and I'm doing it in three minutes
now you've walked for multiple days
suffering the whole time and I'm going to
fast forward through it and I'm
sorry and no, it's fine. I mean,
that's why people need to read
by the book. That's all there.
So you arrive at a camp.
Now we arrived back to the book.
We stopped in front of one
cage and the door opened.
A guard pushed me in and I stumbled over
someone lying inside and fell tumbling
into the ground.
Pain shot through me.
The cage was about 12 feet
wide and 20 feet or so long.
I could not have been
more than four feet high.
26 prisoners were stuffed inside
all south Vietnamese soldiers.
Heat hung in the cage,
heavy and stale.
The air smelled of
filth and putrid wounds.
People moaned in a constant doe rumble.
The occasional whale was met with sharp
chachas and guard guarded whispers.
The doorway was shut and secured.
I lay there thankful I'd survive
the journey of the past three days.
What would become of me now.
Yeah. That was my first, that
was my first prison camp. Uh,
the jungle camp was in the jumble figure
somewhere in northern Cambodia where
the US was not operating
anymore and it was a, a camp of,
of many cages are about
300 prisoners in that camp.
All South Vietnamese that have been
captured in this offensive one other
American who I would meet later. And
uh, yeah, putting one of those cages
back to the book. My broken back
screamed every time I tried to lay down,
try to lie down with my feet
in the stocks. So they'd
put your feet into stocks,
wooden bamboo stocks.
There was no way I could lay on my side.
I couldn't lay straight back.
So I sat upright in the dark in agony.
I thought of my family, fought of my
day of where I'd been, where I was now,
and what might lie ahead.
I heard badly still,
I had hope I can live this way.
I can do this.
I can survive,
I will survive.
I sat there, thoughts drifting
across the landscape of my life,
shaped by these
extraordinary circumstances.
Eventually I fell asleep
sitting up right that night,
dreaming of what might become of me.
I jolted awake,
something scampered across my legs.
Something was on my feet, something small,
cool and wet.
Touched my arches and souls.
Little rat noses poked and sniffed
at my feet. Tiny teeth nod,
my pulverized, raw flesh. My
arms swung without command.
As I batted a large rat off my lap.
Others scurried away. I screamed
inside. Lips pressed tightly shut,
a muffled. The Shriek of terror.
I thrashed my legs, flailed,
but went nowhere.
I wiggled my feet as well as I could
in the socks and got the rats off.
They fled into the night only
to when I fell back asleep,
they would return to torment me nearly
every night in that jungle prison.
Yeah. I don't like rats this day. Uh,
some of my kids just to mess with me.
I'll just bring up rats. As I mentioned,
a rat's I hate. I hate rats
from, from that experience.
And that's not the beginning or the end
of the rat experiences and in prison.
One thing that you did mention though
that I'd like to highlight is, is hope.
Uh, there was a phrase in there that
I wasn't going to give up. Hope.
Hope is such a powerful thing.
Uh, it's there for all of us. Uh,
we just need to grab a hold
of it and hold it tightly. Uh,
hope was all I had for much
of my time in captivity,
a hope of, of, uh,
of surviving a and in that survival
of getting back to my two young kids,
those two kids really played
such a role in having me survive.
My son, when I went over there
was a four and a half years old.
The over for my daughter was newborn.
Uh, but when things would get really,
really tough, I think of
those kids and however bad it
was, I had to endure it, uh,
to do my best to survive and,
and get home to those kids.
Okay.
Yeah. The, the I, I definitely,
that's one of the things that I
specifically highlighted, you know, was,
I can live this way. I can do this.
I can survive. I will survive.
I still, I had hope. Yeah,
and I read it just the way you just
explained it. It hit me that hard.
Back to the book. We sat for a
few more hours. My cage mates,
all Vietnamese soldiers
appear to rag tag crew.
Almost everyone had been wounded,
some gravely filth covered there.
Tattered uniforms. The whole place
stunk of sweat, blood, infection,
feces and urine.
We were all hurting and some would dye.
Some cautiously whisper to their neighbor.
Most like me just sat and stared.
That's what I did.
I sat and stared at them
sitting and staring at nothing.
I wondered if I would go crazy here,
would I die here? What would happen first?
Insanity or death.
Yeah.
I snapped back to what little
grasp by hat on reality.
Hold it together.
Focus.
Spence and Vicky will hike. We'll
play. Get back home for those kids.
You can do it.
You can endure.
Yeah.
I couldn't allow my thoughts
to drift and dark directions.
I forced myself into logical,
structured thinking.
I began planning a hiking
trip with my family, uh,
bactrim backing trip into the woods.
I plan the route,
the equipment loads for each.
They'd be Featherlite for Vicky a little
more for Spence. Amy. I'd carry most
of it. We'd eat dehydrated food,
cooked around a small campfire.
Delicious.
I'll tell you.
Dehydrated food then sounded
awfully, awfully. Yeah, that was,
that was a gourmet meal.
And, and I did that.
I got back from my captivity.
I spent some men,
maybe we'll go into this later
and I won't get all the details of
hospitalization and medical and all that.
But when I got released from
the hospital finally, uh,
took my family on vacation and he guesses
on what the first thing I did on that
vacation,
tell me,
drove to the Olympic peninsula and took my
family backpacking. Uh, your heart, man.
I love and I'm glad that I did.
I mean,
I always enjoyed the wilderness in the
woods and would've been a much worse
shape in captivity if I, if I
hadn't. Uh, but since then, I've,
I've loved the wilderness in the woods
even more. I mean, I love every day,
every beautiful day on God's green earth,
but loved the wilderness in the woods.
We were assigned a Panama for a time.
I don't know if you've been down there and
general school. And when, one thing, my,
my older son, the little four and a half
year old boy was a, was an adult by then,
uh, we backpacked, well,
we did a three day journey across the
isthmus of Panama somewhere where nobody
ever did. We just pick some place, went
from the Atlantic or the Pacific side. Uh,
we did mountain bikes first,
then we backpacked staying in the jungle
and until we got to the Rio Indio, uh,
and it was dry season,
winter planted very well cause we had
to hike way down the Rio Indio before
there was enough water
to hire a guy in a car.
You get canoe to take us out to
the ocean. So I, you know, even,
and that was just before my retirement,
but I, I've always loved the wilderness,
love the jungle. And, uh, yeah, I don't
know how we got on that thing, but okay.
Back back to the book. Well
that's awesome. And one of
the things that I, again,
I specifically highlighted was
the fact that you know, you, you,
you would be drifting in these dark
directions and you would force yourself.
And I talk about that too. You know, I, I
say mind control, not mind control. Like,
Hey, we're going to control your
mind. Control your own mind. Yeah.
And put your own thoughts in there.
Yup.
You can do that and people just need
to learn how to do it instead of we,
you start drifting off in the wrong
direction, control your thoughts,
get mind control.
And I love the fact that you did that we
such with such authority and power over
what, over what your
brain was thinking. Yeah.
I think that's an important message.
And I was a much overused phrase.
Are you a half glass, half empty or
glass half full kind of guy? Uh, I,
I really would advocate for you have
to be a glass half full kind of guy to
survive. And I think I might
carry that argument further.
If you want to have a
happy, full, enjoyable life,
you'd damn well better be a half glass
full kind of person. Uh, if you're,
if I mean there's enough problems
and difficulties in life,
if you want to go for the dark side,
it's, it's there. You can go to it. Uh,
but there's enough positive,
wonderful things. Uh, the, yeah,
grab that beat of hope and,
and go for it. Absolutely.
Back into the
camp and back to the book,
the camp provided a miserable
existence on the edge of madness.
All was filth and disease and suffering.
Moans and whales of pain and anguish
cried from the enclosures as we walked by,
I caught glimpses of sick and wounded
men inside cage after cage, their eyes,
white orbs of desperation,
peering from grimy faces through
the din of the gray world inside
and now you're back in
the stocks sitting there,
wounded in stocks and a bamboo cage and
an unknown jungle prison camp with death
all around me. I began to wonder,
how long can I endure this?
Then my voice said out loud.
As long as it takes.
Yeah.
Incredible.
And here you meet that and in this
prison Cape you meet Wayne. Wayne.
Wait, finished. Yeah.
The other American who was held prisoner
already been captured march, April, May,
a couple months before me.
And you,
Wayne,
the crew now you're going to
get put on a long march. The,
they say we're going to move
you out of this prison camp.
Do you know you're going to Hanoi?
No, no. They, they, they put,
they pulled me out of my cage and I found
myself in the center of the camp with
a group of 25 south Vietnamese
prisoners. Uh, I think they were all,
they were all officers,
uh, myself and Wayne. Uh,
and they told us they were going
to move us to a new camp and the,
and the communist camp commander,
it was running at the mouth and one
of the South Vietnamese officers was
translating for us, but they're
going to move us to a new camp. Uh,
work conditions would, we'd be up,
would be better. I mean, in this camp,
people were dying almost every,
every day. Uh, conditions be better.
We get medical care, we'd
get letters from home. Uh,
but we have very difficult journey.
It could last for as long as 11 days
and we should try very hard to make it.
That's what we were told.
Now the tribe very hard.
The 11 days I guess was registering
in my mind that try very hard to make,
it really didn't fully register
until we actually set out marching.
By this time my ankle wound was very
infected. My leg was very swollen.
It was so painful just to take a step.
And you know,
I was having to take step after step
after step. And as I got into that March,
I was wondering how I was going
to get through the first day.
I didn't think I could do it.
I didn't know how I could possibly
walk for a day through the jungle. Uh,
they, uh, they had as
tied loosely together, uh,
had our arms tied Lusa behind our backs,
no shoes as time.
This was barefoot and off we went.
Uh,
somehow I made it through that
first day and the day after that.
Yeah.
And the day after that,
the trip turned out to be not 11 days
to a new camp somewhere in Cambodia or
even Laos or back into Vietnam.
That trip took over three months.
Uh, and I did end up in Hanoi
at the end of that trip. Uh,
that journey cost the lives
of a, of six of the south
Vietnamese prisoners in Wayne.
The other American died,
uh, before we got to Hanoi.
And I damn near died a number of
times and that's all in the book.
But by the grace of God, I survived and
made it and got all the way to Hawaii.
He also
got to know some of the Vietnamese
south Vietnamese soldiers, one of them,
Lieutenant Dwayne Dean
Zan. Is that right? Yeah.
That's very good son, son, son.
And he was, you know, obviously you,
you formed a really good relationship
with him. Yes. Here we go.
Back to the book we charge. Yes. Let me
interject one. Let me interject one thing.
Cause this is fascinating to me.
It's always been why are,
well I'll come back to it.
Let me see where you're going
to go with the conversation.
You're going to get to my relationship
with him and yeah. Okay, good. Yeah,
absolutely.
We trudged out of the valley
up on to a rising ridge line.
There wasn't much talking. When we
began to climb up with steep long trail,
I was already exhausted.
I had to push hard to make every step
my swollen infected ankle throbbed with
pain. I wondered, is anyone
else having this much trouble?
How long am I be able to keep going?
Only then did the words of the lead guard
really hit me as long as 11 days try
very hard to make it my being revolted.
My being revolted.
11 days of this,
how the hell am I going to be able to
do that in two seconds? I answered.
Got To as long as it takes
reach down deep gotta go.
Keep going. God helped
me. Wayne was stoic.
He was in better shape than I was,
but still it had to be tough for him.
He just bore down and put out
what was needed to keep on going.
Some of the other person's nurse did
as well. Many like me had trouble,
a number of complained and a few cried.
Other prisoners paraded them.
A couple of them fell down and whimpered
and the guards yelled at them slapping,
kicking and hitting them with
rifle butts until they got up.
I thought this is going
to be a long 11 days
and this is just continuing
way past 11 days.
You're now just beyond that. Continuing
with the story. As the days continued,
I became weaker and lost weight.
Fevers followed waves of shivering.
Chills might be malaria.
I suffered from diarrhea,
probably dysentery.
My festering ankle wound hurt more.
The swelling grew worse, aggravated
by the journey. Leeches plagued me,
sucking my blood and adding infections of
their own. My right leg became a heavy,
painful mass that I
dragged along the trail.
I must've been a site though.
My Moo wounds placed me in a worst
situation.
Wayne was sick and deteriorating too.
He had some sort of jungle
fever and lost his appetite.
He quit eating regular rice preferred
only the crispy layer that formed right
next to the surface,
the cooking pot.
What the Vietnamese called
Calm Che or Fireeye's.
Zhan was having troubles to
injuries from his shoot down,
declined from months in captivity,
poor diet disease than the daily
toll of this horrendous marsh north.
Every step of the way,
our personal demons threatened our
physical ability and mental willingness to
press on.
Everyone suffered.
We look like the walking dead struggling
to survive each agonizing mile of that
march.
Most of us stoically face
the challenges that beset us.
Sometimes selfishness and self
pity erupted and tempers flared.
Pain and suffering took its toll.
The senior ranking prisoner and our group
was Pham Van thousand a major in the
South Vietnamese army.
He tried his best to be a leader for
the 25 south Vietnamese officers and two
American helicopter pilots under
the most trying conditions.
The enemy gave him no authority to lead.
I had a lot of respect
for what Tom tried to do.
I felt the frustration he had to endure.
Morale sunk lower and lower.
Bickering grew rampant.
Prisoners died. Don was senior,
but most dismissed his efforts
as they struggled to survive.
Okay.
And now there's a prisoner
that goes down on the trail.
The guards yelled back
and forth at each other.
They ranted at the prisoner
lying on the ground.
They barked orders to the rest of us.
I didn't understand any of it.
Zhan said softly, but earnestly to
Wayne in me. Keep walking. No stop.
We continued. One guard stayed with
the prostate prisoner where he lay,
we walked on after a short while,
Bang,
one shot. Sometime later,
the guard guard caught up.
Adult sense of disbelief
and shock overcame me.
I had no doubt what had just happened.
I kept walking as I cried.
It was clear.
If you could not march,
you would die.
Yeah. And that message really
settled into my mind at that point.
And I knew if I ever got to the
point where I couldn't march anymore,
that would probably happen to me as well.
The aside that I wanted to
say about sung, uh, was,
and it was mentioned song was a
Vietnamese air force pilot. Uh,
he was young and strong and in my mind
he was a lot bigger than he was because
he's still a short statured Vietnamese.
He was the [inaudible] pilot that I saw
shot down on my way to Ben hit that I
asked for permission to go help rescue.
Yeah.
We put that together shortly after
we started that March north of,
you know what he was flying where he was
when he was shot down. I said, my God,
we were shot down the same day.
Yeah.
And that's why,
that's one of the reasons I included
that piece because that was such a,
such a coincidence or
fate that you guys were,
that was in there.
You were,
and he turned out to be such a
good friend and I, oh my. Well,
I owe my life to several
people. Wayne Finch, uh,
[inaudible] especially
for what he did for me,
back to the book, the journey
was a nightmare, a horrid
soul wrenching nightmare.
It grew worse.
Others fell out and died each step
everyday racked my body with pain.
My infections became worse.
Disease was taking me.
I knew I was sliding closer to death,
but I kept fighting as hard as
I could to keep my spirits up.
I continually thought,
continuously thought of my family of
things I would do with Spencer and Vicky
when I got home. Thinking of
those two kids gave me strength,
always bolstered my hope.
My leg was now swollen
to twice its normal size.
Dark colored filled with pos,
long splits formed in the skin plus and
bloody stinking fluid oozed from the
cracks.
I dragged it along like a sodden club.
Every movement,
every movement lashed me with searing
pain that kept my face contorted.
I shrieked a silent cry within
pain burden to black and scarred.
Deep in the center of my soul.
Gangrene set in my bloody
dysentery worsened.
I had chills and fevers.
I would find out later that I had
three different kinds of malaria
each morning I fought a battle to stand
and with all that going on,
I tried to maintain a sense of humor.
It was hard,
but it was necessary. Spirit is the
most important factor in survival.
A sense of human humor,
even under the worst conditions helps
maintain spirit and in spirit lives.
Hope I was determined to survive.
Still,
I owed so much to Wayne and Zam.
They helped me during the through the
worst and we're always concerned about me.
They did all they could to help me.
Zhan especially helped me
remain positive to be hopeful,
as bad as things ever got.
I never gave up hope.
I mustered all my will
each day just to wake,
stand and take a step.
Then I fought hard for the
remainder of the day to keep going.
Moving along the trail, I could
barely walk, but somehow I did.
I survived each day to open my eyes in
the morning to the gift of one more dawn.
The realities of my miserable world,
we're clear DEF are constant.
Companions stalked us,
waiting for us to give into
its relentless temptation.
That would be the easy thing to do.
In normal life,
you have to take some overt action to die.
You have to kill yourself
as a prisoner of war.
Under these circumstances
that is reversed.
You have to reach deep within yourself
and struggle each day to stay alive.
Dying is easy.
Just relax,
do nothing,
give up and peacefully surrender,
stop gagging down food, stop
struggling to walk, stop fighting,
then you will die.
Many did.
So that's an incredible paradox
that you point out there.
Yeah. But it's, it's something that
I, that I saw because it is, I mean,
if you give up then you just die.
You stop eating and you die.
It's hard to stay alive and you need
something to motivate you to stay alive.
And I had it. I mean, I can't talk enough
about those two kids and when they,
when they listen to
this, uh, yeah, it's uh,
it's often hard to keep from
getting very emotional, but uh,
those two little kids are probably the
single most important reason that I,
that I survived along with a lot of other,
other things that helped you
in that little four years.
Four and a half year old boy will
celebrate his 50th birthday in April
and you'll be there with them.
I, yeah, yeah, yeah. Beautiful.
Okay.
I think we're getting
to the low point here.
The worst day of my life came
a few weeks into this trip.
I fought hard to continue the march,
but I faltered.
I dug deep inside myself for strength.
There was nothing there.
I dug deep.
I staggered on and faltered again.
I struggled more.
I reach deeper,
yet I prayed for more strength.
There was none.
Yeah,
I collapsed.
I got up and stumbled along.
I collapsed again and again and I
got up again and again. I fought,
fought with all I had in my body,
heart and soul.
I collapsed and couldn't get up.
I could not. We'll myself up.
I was at the end of my life.
The guard looked down on me.
He ordered me up. He
yelled at me. I could not.
It was done.
I knew my life was here on this miserable,
muddy jungle trail.
It was over.
Okay.
Would my family ever know
what had happened to me?
Then? Zhan was there looking,
worried, bending over me.
The guard yelled at him to stop.
Undeterred Zhan reached down to help me.
The guard yelled louder, but zones
face was set with the termination.
In spite of whatever threats the guard
was screaming. Zhan raised me up,
turned and pulled me
onto his frail weak back.
He wrapped my arms around his neck and
class my risk together in front of him
the rest of the day. He pulled me along
my feet dragging on the ground behind.
Part of the time he was
helped by Lieutenant Hoang,
knowingly a big ambitious
brute helped briefly,
but it was on on who
carried the burden that day.
It was on who risked his own
life to lift me from def.
It was on who carried me and cared for
me until we completed that long days
struggle had another wayside camp.
Yeah, I definitely owe him my
life. Absolutely. Absolutely.
You end up falling into a river as well.
Yeah.
That's the next day when we tried to
set out and I couldn't get back up.
I remember my ankle wound was so infected
I could barely move that leg and yeah,
three kinds of malaria dysentery.
Then three kinds of intestinal parasites,
malabsorption syndrome. I
was just a bad, bad way.
Okay.
You fall into this river back to the book.
Zohn and Wayne came off the log and
down behind Steepbank to my rescue.
They waded into the turret,
pulled me back onto the bank with
Wayne shouting in English and on and
Vietnamese.
They pleaded for the group to stay at the
camp until I was able to travel again.
They were ordered away.
They wouldn't leave me.
Guards dragged them away and force
them across the log bridge at gunpoint.
They marched off with the
rest of our prisoner group.
Everyone believed I was left at that camp,
the die.
So you get left by that group? I do. And
you go to another camp where they
kind of let you recover a little bit?
Yeah.
Well I actually stayed in that camp and
for some reason the decision was because
I hadn't had any medical treatment to
that point at all for, for for months. Uh,
and at that camp with me laid up there,
they've got the camp medic and came
over and I got some shots of penicillin.
Uh, I, I guess the only reason for this,
the decision was we were along the trail
and head north and they wanted to get
me to annoy if at all possible.
So they did give me penicillin shots for
about five days running and as soon as
I could stand up again and put any
weight on my leg at all, then off,
off we went back on the trail and
now you're on the trail to be,
you were the one guard at this point,
1,000,001 guard going
north yet suit duties.
You too,
and you're again,
you're hiking again,
challenging terrain and
going back to the book,
we continue day after day after miserable
day, the journey was taking its toll,
stretching my will to press on again.
It's like you just keep getting to the
bottom and finding more unbelievable.
Each day's trek demanded more
than I thought I had to give.
I was able to go on only by scraping
up the few remaining bits of grit that
remained in the most obscure recesses
of my heart and soul. I prayed,
I commanded, I willed myself to
take step after impossible step.
That effort itself,
fed in agony festering within me,
which swelled and nod at my core as weak,
followed wretched week.
Malaria tax and bouts of
bloody dysentery tortured me.
The pain of my broken
back pierced me every day.
The soles of my feet were mosaics
of raised welts and open bleeding,
dashes and punctures. Previously broken
toes throb as I broke them again.
And as always there was
the pesky leash leeches,
but I was still alive
and for that I thank God.
Okay.
And not only did you think God,
you also still tried to
escape in that state?
That was one of the stupidest things I
did in my entire captive. There'll be yes.
I, you know, I had that in the code
of conduct, escape, escape, escape.
And we had planned even in
that first jungle camp, uh,
had planned on escape
from there with Wayne. Uh,
but it was because of my poor
condition that Wayne said, let's,
we're going gonna wait till you get some
strength or this isn't going to work.
And then of course I took us off on the,
on the trip that Wayne didn't survive.
Uh, but yeah, so the day that I'd
finally did, I may have an opportunity,
you mentioned I was with one guard.
We'd often travel with groups of other
groups in north Vietnamese is going up
and down the trail and we were traveling
with one such group this day. And uh,
I don't know where you're going to
pick up the stories. You can tell.
Just tell him. I'll tell part. So, uh,
my guard zoo is talking to some other
North Vietnamese guy and they left and I,
we're all in a big group and so they
fall behind and I'm still with the main
group,
but I'm just kind of slowing down in
the group was moving away from me and I
came around one turn in the trail,
one corner, no Jew behind me,
no group in front of me. So just in
that instant I said, this is my chance.
And plus I knew about where we were near
the demilitarized zone and we were only
several miles from the coast.
So that's in the back of my mind.
I think I could make it so I just took
off the trail and headed up the side of a
hill with my great escape,
which only lasted for a very
few Mo. I don't even know the
last two minutes, but a very few,
few moments before I was recaptured.
Where are you going to read some of that?
Yeah, this is what happened.
You do get recaptured. Here's
your thoughts. I'm dead.
It's all over.
The zoo hovered over me.
His Ak 47 muscles shifting from the center
of my face to the middle of my chest.
He shrieked you. You. Why
you? His face burned red.
His eyes wild and rage spit sprayed
as he screamed at me. This is it.
His fingers on the trigger.
He's going to kill me and then you,
I missed the trail. I got
lost. He didn't shoot.
He pointed his rifle away in
a solid voice. He commanded.
Get up. You do very bad.
You have big problem now.
He was shaking it raged.
He motioned down the hill and said,
go.
Yeah.
Nothing more than it was ever done to me.
Never heard about the incident again.
My psychological assessment is,
uh,
he was so embarrassed and would have been
in so much trouble. Worried, I think.
Yeah. Well, how'd you lose your principal?
I was talking to some guy on emotion.
He's just like, you know what, we're just
going to cover that one out. Yeah, he was,
you know, out of all the guards that
I encountered, he was about the worst,
the meanest despise me the most, I think
of almost anyone that I encountered.
And lucky me, I get stuck with
him being my one single guard,
that it was moving me after I got sick.
Was He with you with that original group
and then he stayed with you with your
back? What? I've got to that first
jungle camp, living in the cages,
he was our interrogator there.
I almost actually felt sorry for the guy.
His alias was so bad. It was as bad as my
high school level. Spanish was. I mean,
he just could barely speak
English and he's trying to,
terra gator some propagandize
this and all this. But yeah,
so he was the only guard, the really
spoken in English at all. So when I,
when I had to be separated from the group,
they,
they assigned him to be the one to
stay back with me and move me Norris.
And now again, fast forward,
you're now on a truck. You're,
you're now moving in vehicles. Okay.
We got into north,
we have walked all the way up across the
north or to the north Vietnamese border
on foot. So we're all the way just north
of the demilitarized zone at this point.
Uh, and then they put us on trucks
to move us into north Vietnam.
And inside North Vietnam we'd
some nights move and trucks,
some days and nights
would, would, would march,
depending on the threat
from American airstrikes.
And of course the trucks are these
old Soviet era things with no shocks.
And by the way,
you have a broken back at this point.
And it's not like the roads in north
Vietnam or in any kind of condition.
So when we first got on the trucks,
I mean after all this death,
March north mind my, my attitude was
haul trucks. This is wonderful. God,
thank God.
And got on the bed of that truck.
It took about a minute and a half of
driving down the road and that truck with
no shocks, no springs
slam, slam slam to uh,
yeah and you literally had
a broken back at this point.
I literally had a broken back and,
and of course,
as you said,
I think you described this to your
wife as series of unfortunate events.
So yes,
now you're out there and
you see a flare in the sky.
You recognize immediately, you
know what's coming. You know,
it's in his first two are
flying Mohawks up off the coast.
We would pick up targets on radar at
night of the convoys moving along highway
one inside North Vietnam and we turn
it over to f four fighter jets from the
four 92nd 97th,
a fighter wing out of Thailand.
And they were called the night fighters
and they'd drop flares and then strike
the target. So yes, I knew
exactly what was taking place.
So you yell out air strike.
And then here we go back to the book,
the first f four screamed
down from altitude and bombs
exploded nearby. And v I,
N. T. O. N. V,
a antiaircraft fire responded the
next f four screeched toward us.
More bombs,
more anti aircraft.
I began repeating the Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want.
Yea though I walk through the
Valley of the shadow of death,
I will fear no evil for thou art with me,
for Thou art with me.
Good God.
The earth shook.
Our truck banged about as if an earthquake
soldiers yelled from other trucks,
system were hit,
the world shuttered and explosions
and flames than it was done.
That was our first,
yeah.
First or second night on trucks
after we got into north Vietnam. Yes.
So not only did I have the
unpleasant bouncing around,
that was extremely painful. All,
sorry, I think I mentioned that book.
Got a horrible case of
heartburn at night too,
is I got all this sour belts is going
on and a, and then we got that, uh,
that airstrike.
And again,
that wasn't the first or last
airstrike that I experienced,
but that was pretty horrific.
And they hit some of the vehicles that
we're going to do some of the Vietnamese
soldiers now. Yeah. And I was by, at this
point when I got right to the border,
just pouring out of the trucks,
I was married up with a second
group of South Vietnamese prisoners,
senior officer's south
Vietnamese prisoner.
So our group of prisoners
was on one truck. But yeah,
other trucks in a convoy got hit and
people killed. And Luckily we didn't.
Now you get into another camp,
and I'm going back to the book.
The guards took us to a small hut with
posts and enough to tie our hammocks a
fast in the door shut in place,
local militia guards outside.
We settled in getting comfortable
and arresting the door opened.
A guard came in and said
something, a South Vietnamese
prisoner enter behind him.
Lieutenant Hoang.
My God,
I knew it was Wayne who
had died in this camp.
Captain Wayne Finch. Wayne
was dead. My God hung,
stared as if at a ghost. Astounded
to see me alive. He cried.
I sat slump devastated at the
realization that Wayne Finch was dead.
My friend Wayne, who had helped
me, cared for me. My friend Wayne,
who I owed so much,
he was dead.
Okay.
Shocked. Disbelieving I
introduced, hung to the others.
He told us how everyone
thought I was dead.
How the group suffered on the
march north after they left me,
how to tall American pilots, join them.
How Wayne continued to get sicker,
lost hope, and grew week.
I fell into sadness,
twisting it into melancholy,
self pity,
sinking to the lowest point I had.
No.
Okay.
And that had to be to be devastating.
It, it was, you know,
we had been separated and when I got
to this camp with the new group of,
of South Vietnamese, uh,
when we arrived at the camp,
the camp commander gave a
speech and I could hear him say,
Finn Finn in the south, one of the South
Vietnamese officers translate for me.
He said, do you know of a Finn? There was
an American fin that died in this camp.
And I said, no, I don't know
any Finn. Uh, but what I did,
what I should have put together with the
bad pronunciation was finished and hung
had been one of the guys helped drag me
through the jungle with, with the sun.
And as soon as I saw hung, I knew that,
uh, that it was, it was fenced. Yeah.
They took me to see the grave where
he was, where he was buried. And,
and at least that rough idea of where
we were helped me when I came back to it
in my debriefs to,
to get that location to the Americans
that eventually it took a few years,
for several years, Williams' body
was, was recovered and brought back.
But that was, that was a low morale
point for me on the trip. That was,
that was devastating. You going
to go into the potato story? No.
Tell the potato store.
Okay.
I'll tell the potatoes because
this is another guy there, there,
there two Vietnamese.
I mean a lot of people help me
all equal. I survive. Yeah. Tell him,
tell him potato story and then
I'll wrap it up for you cause yeah,
tell the potato story. Okay. How are
we doing? How are we doing on time?
We're just going on and on
and on. We're good. All right.
Um, song, it all, it helped
me as we already do described,
but in the second group of prisoners a,
I came to know a one, uh,
lieutenant colonel, Cane Yam, uh,
who today lives in San Jose, California.
Still a dear friend. But Kay,
when he was captured a had a gold
cross pen, I mean, real goals.
It was a very valuable pin. When he was
captured, he hit it in the lining of his,
of his uniform and he was going to trade
it for something for his own benefit.
When, when he got to wherever
he was going to get to.
So I'm in the state that you've described.
I'm just physically a wreck now.
Emotionally, mentally in a low,
uh, were being held at a, at a hut.
There's a local militia guy guarding
it outside. K goes to the wall,
a thatched wall and talks to the guy and
I see him hand his pen out to the guy
and the guy disappears.
Couple hours later,
the guy returns with a small bag and
passes it in the bag were six potatoes.
So Kay had traded his valuable crop.
Gold cross pen for six potatoes,
had a potato cooked each day
for the next six days for me.
And I ate it.K wouldn't take any potatoes.
None of the other Vietnamese senior
officers would take any of the potato.
They were from me. And just, I mean,
both the physical strength the potatoes
gave me, but even more importantly,
just the mental lift that,
that his sacrifice a gay from a
really brought me out of my, uh,
out of my doldrums there. And, and,
and gave me the spirit to go on.
Unbelievable.
The, uh, one more thing that
happens with Kay. You're,
you're getting ready to leave the
camp to go to a new camp, right?
And K tap my arm.
Look,
he said the curious militia guard had
been so interested in learning about South
Vietnam and America.
Who'd fetched my potatoes?
Stood there looking like
a kid with a new puppy.
He came close to the truck and I
lean against the state. Decide,
okay,
goodbye. He said, grinning is simple.
Humanity made me smile and I said goodbye.
Case on my astonishment. He wants to learn
to say goodbye to you when you leave.
I teach him. He good man. Yes. I thought,
okay.
No doubt he is. There are good men
everywhere. It's the governments,
the systems, the leaders that are
bad. It's communism. That sucks.
Not The people of North Vietnam.
They are not so different from the south.
Not so different from me.
I learned a lot of lessons on this trip.
Um,
I learned a lot of lessons about humanity
and people and I do honestly believe
we are all God's children.
Know you.
And I had the good fortune to be born
where we were born in this wonderful
country of ours.
Uh,
others have had the not so good fortune
a bi came across good people in,
in Vietnam. Uh, and he though
he was my enemy, uh, was,
was one.
Sometimes people ask me if I,
if I have any hatred for those guys and
the treatment that I got and I, and I,
and I don't, uh, I don't, uh,
I think they were human beings,
not so different than you
and me. Uh, they had their,
their news controlled by their government,
their propaganda.
Plus they were suffering
airstrikes and everything else.
They behave the way that they,
they behaved.
I guess the one guy is still don't
care much for it. Was it sue?
But we'd probably get over it if I ever,
if I ever met the guy. Uh, so no, I don't,
I don't have any hatred. They're, uh,
they're just people like, like uni.
And there was even times,
I mean,
where you're walking through a village
and now you're in north Vietnam where
what you're just talking about,
they'd been bombed.
They lost their sons and they're trying
to basically attack you to throw rocks
at you. Right. And the guys
that are guarding you actually,
I don't think they shot at them,
but they fired me over there and shot
over their heads to to protect you all.
Yes.
Which I've found to be.
Yeah.
My south Vietnamese friends,
I mean you'll talk to people who have
experienced in the Vietnam war and you get
all kinds of different opinions of the
South Vietnamese and good, worthless,
whatever. And, and they have are
all all varieties like we are,
there are some that fought
valiantly bravely like the
guys at Firebase, Charlie,
uh, the people that I was
with is a prisoner of war.
War were great human beings.
And when we get attacked, yeah, the
first thing they put me at, they've,
that the communist guards,
it's took me in the middle but then the
south Vietnamese willingly with foreign
perimeters around me and then the guards
are on the outside firing is necessary.
Alta
to protect me.
One time going back to book, the
Guard starts screaming, be nom.
Hey, be nom hey and bottom line,
bottom high, bottom high them,
which leads me is Bobby
numb five high too.
And for those of you that don't
translate that real quick,
that's be 52 the bombs dropped.
Hundreds of bombs fell are all around us.
Big bombs nearly on top of us.
I knew there was little chance
of living through a B 52 struck,
but by the grace of God,
no bombs fell in our creator.
The earth trembled at shook.
It ruptured and heaved.
Waves of crushing pressure blasted through
a squeezing, hurting my head and ears.
The suffocating pressure was
painful, awful, frightening.
It stopped all was cry
it. I was dead. I knew it.
I felt ringing in my years,
throbbing in my head.
I must be alive next to me. The
officer's sat up unholstered his pistol.
By the way, you'd be the guy drawn
his pistol and held it to your head.
You made sure he does rescue
during the beef. 52 straight. Yeah.
Kay was moving. Oh, there's began sitting
up days but alive. No one could hear,
no one spoke. We crawled out of the
hole and started walking and direction.
We'd been traveling.
Yeah, this was in, in north Vietnam.
We'd come upon an area of a lot of bomb
craters had been bombed frequently.
And then, uh, the enemy shot
to anti aircraft rounds.
That seemed to be their signal. Two
rounds was a, uh, was an airstrike.
And then the other started shouting bottom
high and all hell broke loose upon us.
Now you get to Hanoi,
right?
And you get a bed. A board. Okay. Board.
There's a blanket though.
There was a blanket.
It gets cold in heaven and French bread.
Is that a style you called it [inaudible]
it's like a small piece of French
bread is what it looked like.
But it was just,
I mean it was kind of half rotten and
pieces of rock and stick and in it was,
it's funny even in the book because when
you first talk about the French bread,
French bread and did a club
run tears to my eyes, a couple,
a couple of paragraphs or
maybe a couple of pages later,
you're saying there was bugs in,
but when you first got that French bread,
the first I was put in
solitary confinement,
my first prison and I was brought a meal.
And now the whole time I was
captured down in the jungle,
we got a ball of grapefruit, grapefruit
size, ball of rice in the morning,
a grapefruit size ball of rice
in the evening for our food.
That's what we got hiking up
the Hotel Minh trail. We would,
in the evenings they would cook rice.
The communist would,
and we would get about that same
equivalent about a ball size of rice.
And then we would roll up a
ball to eat during the, uh,
the journey on the next morning.
So it was the same thing to
grapefruit sized balls or rice a day.
And that's all that I had with
an occasional piece of Manuk.
Uh, yeah. And maybe some, uh, oh,
what the heck do they call it?
Bamboo shoot occasionally, but
mostly just rice. So I get to Hanoi,
I'm in solitary confinement. They
bring me a meal. It's a plate of a,
of a bean sprouts for a plate of bean
sprouts with this piece of French bread on
the side. And I'm sitting there
for a lot of reasons. I mean, I,
I knew that I was in Hanoi.
I knew that this horrible trip of walking
every single day and not knowing how I
was going to survive through the day. All
that was over. I'm here, I'm in Hanoi. Oh.
Plus they'd given me a bath and gave
me a prison uniform and shaved me.
Uh, I mean, I had not shaved the whole
time, so I've been a prisoner for months.
I have this huge beard. Um,
and I sat there and they
brought that food and I did,
I cried.
Tears rolled down my cheeks.
I knew for the first time
since I was shot down,
there was no doubt in my mind.
I was going to survive.
That was no longer a question I had to
do was gut out those last however long it
was going to be in Hanoi.
They had given me this wonderful food
of bean sprouts and this piece of crappy
French bread.
But it was,
it was wonderful. That's, yeah. Beautiful.
And here's,
uh,
as this continues here in Illinois,
I'm going back to the book.
I stood in the cell about 12
feet wide and 25 feet long.
Six bunks lined up to my right head
and against the wall to others lay
lengthwise against the wall.
To my left.
The bunks were three by six foot pieces
of wood resting on saw horses of the
same width.
Each was covered with a bamboo mat.
A blanket neatly folded on one
end between the bunks on my left,
I saw two buckets just like the one
in my ones in my solitary cells.
A row of three small windows slits,
six by 18 inches,
opened high at the back,
at the top of the back wall.
Seven sets of eyes fixed on me.
One approached and put out his hand.
I'm John Murphy.
Captain Air Force,
how you doin Americans?
A room full of Americans.
Whoa,
God bless you.
Then that's your,
you're with these other prisoners.
And
I hadn't seen another American since.
I split up from that group all
that time ago on the trail.
It was a glorious moment to come out
of solitary confinement and be put in a
room with seven other guys.
And
this is one of the things that I talked
about you as we were getting ready to
record, I said, look,
I want to read your entire book on
this podcast because it's so good and
nobody's going to
want to go by the book. Now.
They just heard the whole,
the whole book read to it.
And in one of the decisions that I made
was one of the things that you do in
here is this is a book about you,
but you do a wonderful and a beautiful
job of describing and telling the stories
of all these other heroes that
you're with. And as a matter of fact,
you call this chapter chapter 12 in the
company of heroes with all these other
Americans that you know,
you,
you told me on the way over here and you
talk about it in the book you'd been in,
you were there for, at this point, what,
six months were you there at this point?
Seven months? Yeah, something like that.
Some of these guys had been
in captivity for three years,
five years, seven years, seven years.
The one guy talk about another,
Jim Thompson had been a
prisoner for nine years. I,
I felt I needed to do that in this book.
I've had some real mixed
feelings about writing this book.
I didn't want to do a book focused,
you know,
this happened to me story and I did all
this great stuff. I know I suffered,
but there were so many other prisoners
from the southern experience,
and that's a story I wanted to tell this,
this different southern experience is
different than the prisoners were shot
down and captured in the north.
So many of these guys, many,
many of these guys suffered
so much more than I did,
spent so much more time in
captivity than I did. Uh,
so I do share those stories of
those guys in the company of heroes.
When I got the Hanoi,
got into the prison of plantation gardens,
I met these other guys and they had
the truly incredible heroic stories to
share.
And you do a phenomenal
job in the book of,
of describing, you know them, who they
were or what they've been through.
Bill gone. Al Krol. Boff Yup.
John Parr cells. Bill Thomas,
Bill Henderson, Dave Mott,
just you go through the guys know those
were the guys in my cell and I don't
know, I don't know if you caught in
there. Out of the eight guys in the self,
four of us were named bill.
That's just crazy.
Eight Americans in a cell and four of
his name bill. So I became new bill.
Uh, there was a bill gap was an air
force pilot, but six, four, six, five,
he was big bill.
There was a marine warrant officer who
is some prehistoric elderly gentleman.
The poor guy was 36 years old. We
couldn't believe he'd survived. Uh,
but he was old bill. And then
we had a, a an air force,
a ob 10 pilot who became young bills.
So we had four bills out of the,
out of the eight guys. But yeah,
then then the, the others and they,
those guys had all suffered too. But
then there were other guys in the camp,
uh, shoot, uh, Dennis Thompson and,
and Harvey, uh, brand, uh,
two special forces guys capture along way
their experiences. Uh, so many others,
five, five guys, but TV station in
way who are captured and tet, I mean,
who would think that a TV, radio station,
TV station crew would get captured,
but they had all of their and
their trials and, and then,
yeah, the most was, uh,
was Jim Thompson and his nine years
of suffering as a prisoner of war.
And one of the guys I do want
to highlight is Colonel Ted guy,
someone to go to the book who are senior
or senior ranking officer. Yep. Please.
And someone's briefing, you kind
of telling you what's going on and,
and here's what, um, here's what
Dave says. Dave Mott, he says,
the SRO that's the senior ranking
officer for the camp is Colonel Ted guy.
He's in the shed up on top of the camp.
That's where they've segregated the
senior officers in NCO is from the rest of
us.
He's an air force lieutenant colonel who
must've been promoted to full bird by
now. He went down over
Laos and an f four in 1968.
He's a good leader and a real hard ass.
He runs a tight ship,
doesn't allow making any
propaganda statements.
No one can accept early release.
We live by the code of conduct.
He's taken a lot of beatings and
torture for us. We call him the hawk.
Al Crow. Both jumped in immediately.
Yeah. And we're hawks heroes,
just like Hogan's heroes on the TV
show only. We don't have as much fun.
He had a shit eating grin on his face.
He also looked like crap.
So that's why I thought it was. Um,
that's one of the, you know, you,
you again,
you go through all these guys and what
they've done and you also talk about,
you talk about some of those heroes that,
that held the line and you also talk
about another group who I'll go to here.
Okay.
Sometimes I could hear a lot of noise
from the other side of the wall separating
our road cells from those on
the further end of our building,
I could see the top of a basketball hoop
and occasional volleyball arched high
over an out of sight net.
What's up with that? I asked,
that's the peace committee came the
answer. What's the peace committee?
Eight guys who collaborate with the enemy.
They've been ordered to stop,
but they won't. They studied
communism. Do propaganda,
make radio broadcasts,
even rat on other Americans for that.
They get packages,
get to write letters and can go outside
whenever they want and play games.
We call them the ducks because
of the way they followed,
followed the guards around and do
their bidding. They'll rot in hell.
I said that they will.
The collaborators were,
but a small but significant
minority among us.
There were 107 prisoners
that plantation gardens.
And except for the eight in the
peace committee, all we're patriotic,
loyal Americans who resisted
enemy interrogations,
propaganda and pressure to sign
statements and make rock radio broadcasts.
We resisted with everything we had.
And then, you know, you've got more time
tying those guys back to Colonel Guy.
I can't say enough about Colonel Guy
and he's passed away several years ago
now. Uh, but what, uh,
what a strong leader in,
you know,
we talk about military discipline and
the requirement for it and officer's
dissonance is that whatever in prison
camp that discipline was so essential and
so sought after by everyone.
And we were lucky to have a colonel
guy as our senior ranking officer.
He was so tough and,
and,
and by the rules and the
code and thank goodness,
cause that's what we all
needed to hear. Uh, and to,
and to have that standard to
a, to live by, uh, just a,
a great and wonderful human being.
When we got back, uh, you know,
there were several who would've strangled
some of those peace committee guys,
especially some of our special forces
guys were captured with us. Uh,
but colonel guy put out an order
and he said, this is a direct order.
Everyone stay away from the peace
committee. I'm going to take care of this.
I got it.
Don't you do anything?
And Colonel Guy Press charges against
the peace committee again and again was
overwritten charges were
never brought against them.
But what did happen is
colonel guys career was,
was curtailed Farber short
before it should have been.
But I have the deepest respect for him
as our, as our senior officer. Yeah.
Yeah. And again, I'm going to,
I'm going to say this again.
You go through these stories of,
of some of the other
heroes you just mentioned,
Dennis Thomas Harps and right
there at Thompson Harvey brand,
Bill Murray.
I mean you just,
you go through these stories and then
they're just all phenomenal and you do
them such, such an honor
telling their stories. So,
uh, buy this book so that
you can read these stories.
Cause I don't have time to go
through them all here. Right.
The Oh the one thing I want to point
out though is going back to the book,
we also tried to keep our humor
going within the cell and Alan,
me as the central culprits telling
disgustingly bad jokes back and forth.
Owl was getting a lot better. His nausea
was subsiding cause he was really sick.
His naughty with subsiding
in his boils healing.
Some of the guys exercised to fight
the deterioration of their bodies.
I couldn't even lie on my back,
let alone trying to do sit ups.
What I could do was get,
was try to get into a
position to try pushups.
I tried once in the jungle and failed.
I couldn't raise myself up off the ground.
Now I was able to push all the way
up once and halfway through a second.
Pretty sad for a guy who
could do a hundred pushups
before I kept at fruit added
for weeks until I was able to do
several as part of my daily routine.
And the reason I point that out
is because I always say, you know,
cause people get injured. People come
with sickness. Do what you can. Yes, yes.
And do what you can. And that's
exactly what you are doing. So,
so important.
December 8th ninth or December,
1972 after many weeks of quiet,
we got bombed like none of us had ever
been bombed before. Air Raid, sirens,
wailed, barrages of Sam's
fired and bombs poured down.
American be 52 is that arrived
in forest over underway.
Bombs fell close and plantation
gardens shook. We lay on our bunks,
hoping our bombers knew
where our camp was. Still,
we fell back into a mindset
we'd all developed in captivity.
What will be,
will be no sense in worrying about
something you absolutely have no control
over, which is going to stop
above from landing on her head.
Yeah.
That was the Christmas bombing in 1972
that Nixon ordered to finally bring the
communist to conclude.
Yeah.
Yeah. And I, I, I had to
put this part in here.
I had to read it. Go. So after those,
after that massive bombing repercussion.
So there's a guard that you,
that you had nicknamed repercussion,
repercussion,
a guard so named because of his violent
outbursts and threats against prisoners
stood against the wall.
As we milled around the water trough,
he spoke some English old Bill
Thomas walked over to them,
him and said,
you think those air strikes were bad?
What the guard asked you think those
airstrikes were bad last night,
bill set again. Yes. Bad bombing.
Well, you ain't seen nothing yet.
Wait till they drop a
bomb on your fucking ass.
I gasped and smiled. Old Bill, proud
marine. He'd been pretty quiet guy,
but not anymore.
We all glowed inside after the bombing.
It was a huge morale boost.
The bombings went on night after night,
not without impunity be 50
two's got shot down there.
Ghastly giant carcasses
burning, falling. We wondered,
sadly about the fate of the crews.
We lost an aircraft yet they kept
coming quietly. We cheered them on.
Yeah,
that that was a huge morale
boost and Bill Thomas, boy,
bless his heart because he was
always kind of a quiet guy,
but he just let it let it all out there.
Yeah.
That's so awesome.
Okay,
now we're wearing them in the
Hondo Hilton. The infamous,
yeah, they moved us in the middle
of all that bombing attacks.
They loaded us up one night on trucks
at the plantation gardens, drove around,
I don't know,
it seemed like for a couple hours.
I think they're just
trying to disorganize.
We thought their tickets down in
the country because of the bombings.
Then they came to a stop and we got out
of the trucks and found out we were only
a few Blauer several blocks from
where we started at the Hanoi Hilton
and now they set up like a little movie
night for you guys. Oh yeah. For the,
at the Hanoi Hilton,
a little movie night and they,
they set you down for the movie night.
You guys are making fun of the projector
operator and finally they tell you
quiet, no talk. And then the
movie starts back to the book.
The film was of Jane Fonda
visiting North Vietnam.
We saw an American cavorting among
the enemy leadership supporting cause
scenes appeared of her climbing into the
governor's seat on an Nva antiaircraft
gun wearing a clean white blouse,
smiling broadly,
laughing,
dawning and north Vietnamese army helmet
with live ammunition at or feet that
would later shoot down American planes.
In the film,
she sent a message to American
servicemen calling US war criminals.
She said we were following the orders of
other war criminals that were like the
leaders of Germany and Japan in World
War Two who were executed for their
crimes.
Yeah,
I was stunned.
We didn't dare speak out loud,
but we had plenty to say to each other
when we got back inside our cell days
later, they showed us some news clippings
from American newspapers and magazines.
They all had news of war protests.
One one was former US attorney general
Ramsey Clark demanding that American
stopped bombing north Vietnamese dykes.
He had been attorney general under
President Johnson during the buildup of
American forces in Vietnam.
Now he was making statements from annoyed
that it was inhumane to bomb dykes and
that we should never do it again.
A photo showed him standing beside
a dyke with a single bomb crater.
I knew we did not have an air
campaign to destroy the dikes.
This was an errant bomb.
The war protesters at home
never bothered me. In fact,
I took pride in fighting communism in
this far corner of the earth so Americans
could have the right to
protest in the streets.
It was a sacred honor to defend the right
of other Americans to disagree with me
or anything within our
American system of government.
Okay?
Yeah. And I, I do believe
that so strongly. They're,
the core of our democracy is not that
we all get in line and March 4th,
uh, I'll take us to 1984. Uh,
the strength of our American democracy
as we can have different views and people
disagree in the health of the democracy
is when those disagreements can be
argued and discussed, and then
you reach a solution, a demo,
or a democratic solution and you go
forward. That's the beauty of our system.
So yeah, it never bothered me. Even during
the war I'd come up, people say, God,
isn't this horrible at these guys?
Know exactly what I said there.
I am fighting as an American soldier
to defend the American way of life,
which is democratic disagreement, an
argument, so they have added guys,
you want to protest?
Go protest.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Now you,
I'm good.
I'm just going to go to the book.
We joined the wrist rest of our cell mates
and pressed clothes to Jose,
Angela Dewa,
Anzel Dewa autonomy rose marine,
a tall marine corporal captured a couple
of years before he quietly related what
he'd gathered from the broadcast, so he
was a translator. He was eavesdropping,
listen to the radio translated.
One of the guards was out in the courtyard
playing a radio, which they never did.
I never heard them,
but obviously there was some important
news coming says guard head is at a radio
out in the courtyard listing and Jose
heard what was said on the radio and he
says it sounded like a peace agreement
was signed in. The war has ended and
you kind of get that confirmed
back to the book. That afternoon.
We were taken in the court yard with our
fellow plantation garden prisoners from
the cell.
Next door.
Film crews stood behind a couple of big
old funky cameras set up on tripods.
We stood in rows as instructed,
waiting for whatever might come
and order passed through the ranks.
Hawk says if it's good news,
no reaction, no smiles,
no shouting, nothing for
propaganda. Yup. I love that.
He's just hard to the end
and then doc,
who's the comp command, the
camp commander, he, he says,
he looks up and says the peace
agreement assigned. You all go home.
He waited for us to cheer
nothing. He looked apologetically
at the film director,
then back to us with a hint of the
scow and he goes through the whole,
the whole points of,
of what the peace accord has in it right
in as he read the remaining highlights
all faded into adult drone.
I'd heard the most important one to me.
The war's over. We're going
home within 60 days. I made it.
Thank you God.
We went back to ourselves.
Yeah, that that was, it was a
manageable Angie. We'll do it.
Getting the heads up and
then we confronted the guards
and the next morning and
they denied no, no, no,
no, and and put, yeah.
Then that afternoon we got let out in
the courtyard and got the agreements read
to us what a,
what a tremendous feeling,
but it was a tremendous feeling and
then stop just short there because we
weren't home yet.
Right?
We weren't going to believe it until
it happened and you still had 60 days,
60 days and they actually consolidate
other prisoners now. Right.
They started doing releases earlier on
or was supposed to be the longest held
and most seriously injured.
The got out first and then the releases
were going to be spaced out in several
groups over a period of 60 days.
Back to the book here,
after the new group joined us,
we'd hear Godawful shrieks
in the middle of the night.
I thought it might be Ted Gustus,
an intelligence officer captured in an
ad hoc way in 1968 he'd been hung from
ropes, denied water, severely
beaten for extended periods,
bashed in the head with
an AK 47 and kicked in the
stomach and an effort to gain
valuable intelligence.
He never revealed goddess was now a
physical wreck who'd been driven to the
precipice of insanity,
sometimes dangling dangerously over its.
But it wasn't Ted who is
screaming in the night.
Okay.
It was Jim Thompson.
Jim Kept to himself.
He was hard to get to know.
But in time he began to open up to me
and share some things about himself.
He was only 39 years old and God,
he looked like hell.
He'd been through more shit for a longer
time than any other American soldier in
history
in nine years.
And you do a beautiful job of
recounting the story that he told you.
So this is the first person,
the first person report of,
of what happened. And again,
it's an incredible,
incredibly horrifying and heroic story
that everybody needs to read about.
And when he finishes telling
you the story of, of, of how,
what he'd been through up to
that point of going back to book,
I looked into his eyes
and saw troubled soul.
He'd survived captivity for nearly nine
years longer than any other American
soldier in history.
It had taken a lot from him.
My God, Jim, that's incredible.
I said he smiled weakly and looked down.
Prisoner releases began a few days later.
Okay.
Yeah.
Jim Is truly an unsung American hero.
Most Americans don't even know of him.
Uh,
the longest held American
prisoner military,
prisoner of war in history.
Uh, those, I mean, most people,
they don't know much about
the Vietnam war anyway.
There's not very much taught in,
in our history books or classes.
But those who do know something
about the Vietnam War,
if you ask them who the longest held
prisoner was, they will respond.
Navy lieutenant of Alvarez,
Lieutenant Alvarez was the longest held
prisoner shot down over north Vietnam.
He was not the longest held
prisoner from the Vietnam War. Uh,
Jim Thompson has several months,
uh,
more time in captivity
then than have Alvarez.
So I don't want to take anything
away from, from Alvarez,
but Jim never got the recognition really.
I mean it's been mentioned here and there,
but as far as people realizing and giving
him the honor that he deserved a never
received that as being the longest held
American military prisoner in history
and he's passed away now.
I regret it.
Well we will do our our best to spread
that word on here and I've actually
ordered a book about
him. Good. And I will,
I will make sure I spread the word to
the best of my ability about his service
and sacrifice and heroism
and
the way you do it in here as an incredible
tribute to what he went through as
well.
Now
the days go by, they finally pack,
get you to pack up your gear,
give you some new clothes,
put you on a bus and take you out.
And here we go. Back to the book,
we milled around for half an hour
talking wants to ourselves and getting no
information from the guards.
The staff car returned and
we were soon back on the bus,
afraid we were heading back to the Hilton,
but when we came to a
row of derelict hangers,
we knew we must be on Hanoi's Guy Lamb,
no GLM Jhelum airport used
by enemy Mig fighters, jets.
Throughout the war,
the bus turned at a shabby hanger with
a Rickety control tower at its side.
I be held,
one of the most wondrous sites I'd
ever seen before us was a big shiny,
beautiful. See One 41 medevac
plane parked on the ramp.
The American flag and a Red Cross
were painted high on its tail.
The words US Air Force were printed
boldly on the fuselage just behind the
cockpit. I cannot describe
the emotion that filled me.
I can't even imagine.
And you guys load up.
Take off pen. Here we
go. Back to the book.
I was happy yet anxious as the
big jet rolled down the runway.
Once airborne, we remained
silent, absorbed in our thoughts.
We seem to be waiting for something,
but none of us knew quite what it was
until the pilot came on the intercom.
Thought you would all like to know that
we have just passed beyond Sam missile
range.
We erupted in a spontaneous cheer.
I was overwhelmed with joy.
It was real.
We were free.
We were going home.
Nothing could stop that now.
Yeah.
Yeah. We really, even though we didn't
consciously know it or talk about it,
we didn't have the feeling that we were
home free until that moment when the
pilot came on and said, cause yeah, we're
the missiles couldn't shoot us down.
We were on our,
on our way headed to the Philippines.
Okay.
I'm going to again skip through.
We're almost,
we're running a little long on time and,
but one of the things I wanted to
point out in here is that you got back,
you're going through,
you're in the hospital,
you're going through some of your recovery
and you get asked to talk a bunch.
Hey, can you come talk to this group,
talk to that group and you're saying, no,
I don't want to talk to you.
You don't want to talk to anybody,
don't want to talk to anybody.
And finally you get asked
one more time and I'll go to the book.
I just want to ask you please
to consider one last time.
This group is the Baton
Corregidor Survivors'
association and they really want
one of the returned Vietnam
Pow [inaudible] to talk
to them at their gathering
tonight. You're the only one still
here. I was blown away. Wait a minute.
These are POW survived the Bataan death
march in World War II and they want to
hear about me after what
they've been through it.
Of course you agreed to do it and
this is the part that I wanted,
especially the vets because
a lot of vets listen to this
by giving me an opportunity
I couldn't refuse.
They made me come out of
my shell and speak publicly
about what I'd been through.
They opened the door to what would become
the greatest therapy possible to help
me deal with all that had happened to me.
Many of my friends who have not been
able to talk about what happened to them
have not readjusted.
Well,
several still have major
psychological issues, haunting them.
A couple of days later, I
got an invitation to speak
to a high school assembly,
which I accepted and the weeks and months
ahead I'd be asked to talk to various
groups and I agreed to
do as many as I could.
I strongly believe that the opportunity
to share my experience has been one of
the principal reasons I've been able to
readjust and deal with life as well as I
have.
That coupled with my faith in God,
love of family and my
inherently optimistic nature.
Yes, yes, yes. I can't,
that is probably the greatest bit of
advice that comes out of this book.
I mean, I came up, I didn't
want to talk to anybody.
I didn't think anybody could
understand what I, what I had to say.
And I think many vets have
the same feeling, uh, you
know, just leave me alone.
I will get through this and
plus you don't know what I,
what I've experienced and you can't
understand if I try to tell you about it.
First of all,
they can understand to a degree,
no one will ever be able to understand
everything that you've been through.
But they can't understand or degree
and they do want the listen. Okay.
That's the receiving end.
For you to be able to share
your experience or for me
over the years to share my
experience again and again and
again and even to write this book.
As painful as that process was
a is a therapeutic process.
It's a healing process to be able to
talk about what you've experienced and if
you think you have demons in your mind,
share those demons to talk about it.
It certainly has helped me. I, I'm, I'm
doing well. I've been through a lot.
I'm doing well and I think a
huge part of that reason is,
is thank you survivors of
Bataan and Corregidor because
I couldn't say no to you
and by doing that it got me started
talking about my experience.
Totally agree.
I totally agree.
It's a beautiful advice
and to close out the story here,
you saying the book that you
greet your children at the time,
you greet your children every day with
good morning. It's a beautiful day
and you explain why you
do that in the book.
In a quote,
I truly believe that every day God has
given me on this earth since I came home
from captivity is a beautiful day.
It doesn't matter if it's raining
or snowing, windy or calm,
hot or cold,
sunny or overcast.
Every day is a gift.
Every day is beautiful
and that is certainly something
that I learned in war.
Not as vividly as you did by any stretch,
but definitely something
that I know to be true.
And it's something that I
talk about all the time here,
that
when you see that darkness,
the light is much more beautiful.
It is.
Okay.
And you know, you put
together in this book, um,
some eight that you call the eight
steps to survival in a pow camp.
And those I wrote right after
or shortly after I got back,
I mean the book was written just in
the last several years with those eight
steps for survival. I put those two
papers shortly after I returned.
And what I love about these is as,
as I read through them here,
they're not just for survival in a pow
camp there for life there for life.
They've been tested in the absolute
harshest of conditions in a pow camp,
but they can be applied to life.
And,
and it's actually things
I talk about all the time.
And it's amazing that that
day or so much alignment,
number one, eat. It
sounds simple, doesn't it?
But when you've got to force down nothing
but plain boiled rice, day after day,
month after month,
eating becomes a difficult chore.
Some found death easier.
Now,
how does that apply to life for me?
Eat,
eat the right foods, eat
healthy foods, boom, done.
You want to stay healthy.
Next one,
practice personal hygiene.
When you are sick and starving,
it's hard to motivate yourself to
keep your body and surroundings clean.
Do the best you can with what you have.
Phil to disease and
disease leads to death.
And
again, for me to apply this to
life, this is about discipline.
And this is about routine.
And this is about pride and,
and maintaining those
things. And even, you know,
we've talked at one of those stories
I talk about on here is the, uh,
the Russians fighting the Chechens.
And one of the things that in the
debriefs into post operational debriefs,
when they lost that first push
down there, they said, you know,
once the guy stopped shaving,
right,
then they stopped taking care of the
weapons that go. Everything goes downhill.
So what, to me, one of the things
that this applies to, I mean,
you're talking about it from also from a
pure health perspective, obviously. Yeah.
But it's also a psychological
factor of yes, yes.
Number three,
exercise.
Set up a daily exercise period.
Do something.
Even if you are in stocks and chains,
you can at least flex a few muscles
and do some deep breathing. Okay?
There is no more excuses ever,
ever, for not working out,
for not doing something physical.
Even if you're in stock,
AIDS and chains.
Okay?
Yeah. Not in a recliner
with a TV on. Unbelievable.
Do not give up.
The fight to stay alive is number four.
Do not give up this fight to stay alive.
No matter how sick you are,
how serious your wounds or
how hopeless the situation is,
there's always a chance you can make it.
Take that chance with your
deepest courage. Fight for it.
Okay.
Made again. You apply this every day.
Look at the opportunities you have.
I mean the opportunities
that a normal person has,
we don't even take advantage of
those opportunities that we have.
We don't even fight for those.
Fight for those.
Number five, established
communications with other prisoners.
Use Your initiative and imagination to
make contact with others and then develop
a chain of command.
Okay.
Build relationships with people. Yeah.
Just build relationships with people.
Number six,
follow the code of conduct.
You must know the code before you
find yourself in a prison camp.
Then you should adhere to the
articles as strictly as possible.
Yeah,
and that doesn't mean it here perfectly.
No one could adhere perfectly,
but adhere as close as possible.
If you waver, come back to it.
Don't waiver and think that you've,
uh,
you've failed and then just
cave in and give in. Yeah,
and that's one of the things, again,
we were talking on the way over here.
That was one of the changes after the
experiences that you all had is what
initiated those changes in the code of
conduct to give it some flexibility,
right? So that so that people could bounce
back from and say, oh I Bro, you know,
yesterday didn't make it.
Today is a new day. Exactly.
And I think that attitude is
perfect for everyday life.
You fall off the wagon on something.
Okay, that doesn't do it. Get back on it.
Okay.
Number seven, keep the
faith. Faith in your family,
your religion and your country.
Maybe all that keeps you alive.
Insane. Hang in there.
You are not forgotten.
Okay.
That needs no explanation.
Right?
And number eight,
maintain a sense of humor.
This is difficult,
but both possible and necessary.
A bit of humor helps keep
away fits of total depression.
And remember,
depression can kill.
So yes,
practice what I preached by my poor
family and close friends. Know My,
my very crazy sick sense of humor.
But a,
I do have one and I did throughout and
I give a couple examples in the book
where some very dire times I would come
up with a stupid humor, but I get it.
Well I've talked about that as well and
why we would be in the worst situations
possible and always someone would
be laughing about something. Yeah.
And that's what like you said,
that's what keeps the spirit going and,
and keeps you on the, on the same side
of things is to have fun with it. Yeah.
Is there anything that, any points that
I missed? I mean, again, I, I don't,
I miss a lot of points. Anything else
that, that, that you would recommend
man or that you wanted one to bring up?
I don't think you missed anything, Jocko.
You covered the book very
thoroughly. Uh, you know, the, the,
the title is through the valley,
my captivity in Vietnam.
And I'm saying that because I hope that
this book will be of benefit and value
to others and that's really what
drove me to finish the book.
I started it and I was
wondering why I was writing it.
But I think when the whole
thing is put together, it's,
it's a story of hope and the power of
hope and how anyone can face very adverse
conditions,
challenges in life,
be be the guys coming back with
PTSD from, from, from combat. Uh,
be it just a single mother somewhere. W
with problems, others with difficulties.
I think in reading this book you can
come out of it with hope and a and
hopefully with motivation to, uh, to
overcome those difficulties and a,
and have a,
have a full,
wonderful and beautiful life
because it is a beautiful thing if,
if we'll just grab a hold of that
beauty and, and go for it and not on
whatever negative aspects there
might be there. There's no doubt.
And even though I did a may
have done a thorough job,
I read less than 10%,
much less than 10%.
There's so much more that you went
through that he experienced and the other
people that you talk about who went
through what they went through.
It's a phenomenal book.
It's a phenomenal book through the valley.
My captivity in Vietnam,
there'll be a link for it. Yes.
So you can go to go to the website
and get right and get it ordered. Um,
you guys know the deal. Do it
quick. So you get a copy of this.
I should add one thing because we talked
about a lot of the negative stuff in
the book. It does have a
happy ending. Happy ending.
At the end of this book is Melanie
Ross reader, my wife. Uh, and,
and that little love story is in there
and how we came together. Uh, but she,
and then the two younger kids, we
talked about Spencer and Vicky, but uh,
also a chat and a, and Chelsea, uh,
have brought such joy to my life
and brought this whole journey to a,
to a conclusion. So, uh,
there's the power of hope and there's
also the power of love that comes out at
the end of this. It's absolutely
a, it's beautiful. It's a great,
is a great book.
And
I can't even begin to express
how appreciative that we
are for you coming here
and sharing the story with us,
your determination and your heroism.
I could literally sit here and
listen to you indefinitely.
And so thank you.
I know you have work to attend to and I
dragged you out here when you're already
working hard.
Uh thanks to you.
Thanks to your cousin
Ryan Summers who actually
okay.
Contacted us through the interwebs
and linked us up together.
So thanks to Ryan for doing that.
Appreciate it. And Actually Echo,
speaking of the interwebs,
if anybody wants to support this podcast,
is there any way that they could
do that? Yes, a little bit.
Actually one question real quick.
What part of your back was broken?
Like your lower back.
T l one t 12 l two all in there.
I'm fuse.
I had just,
well we didn't get it all my
surgeries after him back but I'm,
I'm all fused together and
wire together on my back. Yeah,
I was going to ask what,
what did you eat the whole time but this
rice on the whole time while till I got
to Hanoi and then why I said the bean
sprouts was raped. But what I found,
what I found is the keep that
diet for about three weeks run.
And so I had nothing but bean sprouts
couple times a week for three weeks.
Then we get pumpkin soup,
cabbage soup Kohlrabi and yeah,
and corroborate.
Is there anything I don't really care
for us and it's, I can't go love right.
It's actually, but that was partly
psychological cause I had to eat it.
So I do truly love rice today.
That's kind of vegetarian diet or
less, right? Yeah. Yeah. My was very
low one. Dang. Okay. Um,
yes,
inner webs.
So let we talk about on its
supplementation real quick. Um,
best supplements in the world on it.
You want 10% off on it.com/jocko if your
joints are killing you or if they're,
you know,
degenerating whatever Krill oil.
I recommend also a bunch of performance
stuff, which is, um, like I said before,
supplements a lot of the time can
be junk. These ones, you know, 100%.
Yeah, the good ones, you know,
on a.com/jocko get 10% off.
Another good way to support is
the Amazon Click through that.
We always talk about, it's basically
before you do your Amazon shopping,
click through the website,
there's a little Amazon shop banner.
You Click through there and then do
your shopping and then you know that it
supports that way. Real good
on a subscribe on iTunes
if you haven't already.
I think most people have, but in the event
of you not having subscribed already,
um, do that and leave a review.
If you're in the mood and a,
we have a youtube channel. If you
didn't know that. Uh, I post some,
we post some videos, some Jocko
mcnuggets little excerpts of the,
of the podcasts that uh,
you know,
a little lessons if they don't want to
listen to the whole thing, you know,
two hours or whatever, they can listen to
short, short little nuggets if you will.
Anyway, other inspirational videos, put
some music to them, you know. Anyway,
people seem to enjoy, but yeah, check
that out. Youtube, uh, Jocko bought gas,
youtube channel. Subscribe if you
haven't already. We do have a store,
if you're into t shirts,
rash guards, other stuff. Anyway,
check out that stuff. It's Jocko,
store.com a little bit more
efficient of a process now with that.
So basically you get something now,
it gets you way quicker.
Long story, but it's, it's
solid now. So, um, yeah,
it'll be a good experience. Not that
it wasn't a good experience before,
but it'd be a better experience.
We'll say quicker. How about that?
Maybe not necessarily better or worse than
queer anyway, Jocko, store.com see ya.
If you like any of these shirts or
whatever, you don't get one of those.
You can support that way.
There's some women's stuff on there.
There's some patches, rash
guards, hoodies, you know,
Kosta discipline equals freedom.
That's the thing. Anyway,
psychological warfare. If you're a
running into trouble, if you're getting,
you know, you're trying to
work out and you're, you know,
you feel the weakness like,
oh, I'm going to skip today,
or I'm having trouble
waking up in the morning,
or just maintaining discipline one day,
two days, whatever. What you do is you go,
you search iTunes, right?
Psychological warfare by Jocko Willink.
Get one of the, get the Algo, it'll have
any weakness you have right there, Jack.
We'll help you through it
every single time. Squash,
yeah. Every single time. 100%.
Um, effectiveness. Effectiveness,
yeah. Yeah. And yeah,
those are the ways
to support while you're
clicking through Amazon again,
pick up this book right here.
There you go. Pick up this book
through the valley.
My captivity in Vietnam
by William Reader.
It's an unbelievable book cover to cover.
It's an unbelievable book.
So get it.
Get yourself a copy of extreme
ownership. If you don't have it, buy it.
If you do have it,
if you don't have it by it,
if you do have it by one
for all your subordinates,
your boss and your boss's boss,
do it immediately.
And Jocko white tea,
you can get it on Amazon.
You can also preorder if you
want way of the warrior kid,
order it now.
Order now so you can get a copy of
it when it comes out in other ways,
you can be waiting for it. And that's
not going to be fun. And lastly,
if you haven't signed up for
the master New York City,
May 4th and fifth do it this week.
Prices are going up Friday so,
so,
so get after it,
come to the muster and if you want to
give us feedback or comments or continue
this conversation,
you can find us on the inner webs Twitter,
Instagram that Facebooky we are there.
Are you on social media at
all sir? I am. There's a,
I think it was William reader junior
is the Facebook page. Nice. Yeah.
So friend or follow William Reader Jr
and you'll connect with the kernel here.
Echo is adequate. Charles,
I am at Jockowillink Echo.
Do you have anything else to add?
That is it. Thank you so much. Honor
Sir. Anything else you want to add? No,
thank you both for what you do with this
wonderful podcast and indeed that was,
it was my honor to be here and
be a part of this. Well sir,
that's,
I don't even know how to respond to that.
Thanks again to Ryan Summers for linking
this up. It has been an absolute honor.
Thank you for coming on.
Thank you for writing this book.
Thank you for talking to us today.
But more important,
thank you for your service
to this great nation.
Thank you for stepping up and going
forward into the fray over and over again.
Thank you for your incredible
determination and discipline
and your unrelenting
will.
Okay.
Not only to survive,
but to do so with honor and with
and with humility.
And finally,
thank you for giving all of us,
all of us an example to follow
and for reaffirming to us
that
despite the darkness and
the evil in the world,
and despite the discomfort
and the hardships we face
and the challenges that all
people must confront,
despite all that,
thank you for making
sure that we remember.
Without question
that it doesn't matter if
it's raining or snowing.
When do your calm,
sunny or overcast?
Every day is a gift.
Every day.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Every day
is beautiful
and we will remember that.
And so until next time,
this is Colonel William reader,
an echo and Jocko
out.